and and join with the rest of us as
representative cam grills will lead us
i pledge allegiance to the fire of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
by god indivisible with liberty and
thank you and good morning everybody as
chair of the
house science technology and energy
committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing of bills
referred to the science technology and
energy committee
executive session on pending legislation
may be held at any time
although that is not the plan for today
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting
also by the zoom platform
or by telephone
all necessary access information
has been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
[Music]
six 271-3600
zero
or email h c s
at
ledge dot state dot nh dot u s
in the event that the public is unable
to access this meeting the meeting will
the staff assisting us today is jennifer
four our committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
we'll start the meeting by taking roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence
please also indicate whether there is
anyone in the room with you during the
meeting
which is required under that
or the right to know law
so with that i'll call mr clerk to call
the role
yes
thomas is your microphone
uh it is now okay thank you
uh representatives
here
here i'm not sure if you can hear me my
things kind of work a little funky here
do you get me
okay
here
yes i'm here in portsmouth and all by
myself
i should have added uh that i'm here in
with my wife she's in the house this is
my carrington
i know representative kelly picks us
at my home in plain fields alone in my
office but i have family in the house
[Music]
i am here
i'm currently at my office at uh 345
room 108 in somerset
is an employee in the other room so
thank you
mcgee
here home alone in henniker
studio
okay thank you very much mr clerk
so we are here today to have a public
hearing on two bills senate bill 78 and
senate bill 91.
senate bill 78 will hear first
before we open the public hearing
however i want to just go over
some of the
scheduling for
the next month or so for our committee
we'll be hearing these two bills today
and we'll be having a presentation on
how to finance renewable energy product
projects
we will have one more senate bill that
we have to deal with that senate bill
and we are tentatively set
to hear that bill on may 3rd
monday may 3rd
we may or may not exec bills on may 3rd
we're done with the senate bills we can
start scheduling
work sessions on retained bills
and we will do that
i'll have a discussion with
the uh ranking member to decide exactly
what bills we're gonna tackle and when
so that's the uh the schedule for the
next month or so
and with that i will now
open the public here
on senate bill 78
and i will call on
grant bossie to introduce the bill on
behalf
of senator jeb bradley so mr boss you
have the floor for three thank you mr
chairman members of the committee my
name is grant bosse i'm the majority
policy director for the new hampshire
senate i have good news i believe
senator bradley is available
uh he didn't think he would be available
in time to call in but he just uh
emailed me and said he is here to
introduce the bill
i don't see his name on the list
good morning mr chairman
ah there you are good morning miss
senator bradley good to have you here
yeah how are you
um thank you very much um
pleased to be here today supporting
senate bill 78 a number of renewable
energy advocates asked me to introduce
it
as did um
the chair of the puc
the
it changes the
monies in the renewable energy fund to
be continually appropriated
as opposed to allowing
those dollars to lapse
what has happened
the renewable energy fund is funded from
as you know alternative compliance
payments
um
moving from
the
uh continually appropriated to
non-lapsing
what it has done is caused long delays
in the
issuance of renewable energy fund
budgets
which has created uncertainty
and
significant disruption
and suspension of the programs while a
balance of the fund goes
unused so
the purpose of the bill is to smooth out
uh the funding so that there's certainty
uh for these projects moving forward uh
this bill
passed i believe on the consent calendar
in
the
senate and i commend it to you thank you
thank you senator bradley
we have any questions for senator
bradley representative thomas
yes thank you
chair thanks for taking my question
um could you explain a little more
center on
um
what this change does bill uh
you said it was not
i i believe that the wording you still
have there is a non-lasting fun
did you explain
why we need to go back to a continuously
appropriate language
uh mr chairman uh would it be possible
to uh somehow be better heard from your
conference room it is very difficult for
okay
we'll move a microphone closer to
representative thomas and see if that
helps
um okay my question again senator is um
i understand the language in the current
law still contains uh
that it's a non-lapsing fund but can you
explain more why it needs to have a
continuously appropriated wording back
in there again what does it do
yeah thank you for the question i mean
my understanding is because
of the fact that continually
appropriated is not in the statute
it has in certain circumstances
had money lapsing
that then can't be utilized from one
year to the next if it's continually
appropriated there's no spikes and
valleys
in the financing it can be appropriated
as the projects are moving forward and
so there's not a program suspension
and projects
financing being interrupted
um
i think there's likely to be somebody
from the puc
on this call and they probably better
can answer that question but that's my
understanding
of why this change needed to be made to
prevent the disruptions
to the appropriations coming out of the
renewable energy fund
well thank you always for puc for the
follow on questions thank you
okay next step representative harrington
has a question
well i'm going to do exactly what doug
did i'll wait for the puc maybe they'll
answer my question before i have to ask
it thank you
well just to clarify there is no one
from the puc who has signed up to speak
on this bill
uh all right then maybe i'll ask it now
to senator bradley so in in that case uh
mr chairman i think that madeleine minau
would probably be the best person to
okay ms minnow is signed up to speak so
representative harrington i guess you
can hold your question for ms minnow
yeah i'll wait to see what she says
thank you okay thank you representative
yes thank you mr chairman thank you
senator for taking my question actually
it's a similar question uh
but i'll do i'll ask it anyway um my
understanding has been that often the
funding for many projects
seem to have
stopped around july 1st and many people
had to wait till january of the next
year
to be qualified or to receive the
support for their project
uh would would this bill uh help affect
uh the um
changing that schedule somewhat or not
well i
i'm gonna try to explain it a third time
um that is the whole rationale for the
bill because the existing language
means that there have been starts and
stops
in the funding of these projects so
um
you know the language
on
line two and three of the bill
allows it to be continually appropriated
to smooth out the um the funding so
projects
don't get suspended in mid-stream
thank you senator bradley i have a
question for you
when this legislation was originally
written
it was written in the form
that your bill proposes
but then about
four years ago i think it was
committee of the house
changed the wording to remove that
wording about continually lapsing do you
know why they did that i do not know why
they did that um representative i wish i
did because
we probably could have eliminated this
problem earlier but
that that is the problem has caused fits
and starts
and this bill corrects that it doesn't
um add more money to the renewable
energy fund
it it just allows the smoother
okay thank you representative callie
first i just like to say the yankee fan
do you
envision with everything that has gone
on
that
the puc will still have control of these
funds and i'm specifically speaking to
the changes
that are coming up
should the department of energy pass
so
would this would this affect
others besides the puc
so if that fund was controlled by some
other entity
i'm
i i have not read the house bill 2
that you folks sent us with regard to
the department of energy i know that the
senate finance committee is asking a lot
of questions about that
i am assuming it would not change
anything but
that's a red sox fan okay thank you
okay thank you
so i noticed that uh representative i
mean um ms crampton from the puc is uh
on board with our call here this morning
i have uh made it possible for her to
speak and i know representative
harrington had a question that he wanted
to ask of somebody from the puc
so
ms crampton i'm going to recognize you
first because you had your hand up
so that you can make a comment and then
i'm going to turn it over to
representative harrington for a question
go ahead ms crampton
wonderful thank you very much
representative vose i really do not have
a statement to make but there were a lot
of questions uh surrounding the fund and
why the continually appropriated is
needed and um
the non-null absent as well so i'm happy
okay thank you representative harrington
why don't you go ahead with your
question
thank you thank you mr chairman uh yeah
what i'm trying to find out here is it
sounds like what people are saying is
that
coming because of a
somewhat of an artificial time deadline
that there's money that's in the fund
that doesn't get spent until the next
year is is let me start with that is
yes
in a sense it is so what happens
currently is when the fund is not
continually appropriated
funding
that comes in those are the alternative
compliance payments are able to be used
for projects and programs during the
current fiscal year
so our funding comes in by july 1st
those funds may be used between july 1st
of the fiscal year through
june 30th
and what happens with the renewable
energy fund because we're incentivizing
projects
july 1st is in the middle of the
construction season
and we're
approving projects throughout that
fiscal year
as soon as july 1st of the next fiscal
year starts
without the continually appropriated
language
the funds from last fiscal year cannot
be used for those projects that are
did that
yeah so you're saying so july 1st it's
shut off but
doesn't where does the money then go
does it does it roll forward into july
2nd so it can be reappropriated or
no if it was continued that's what it
used to do when it was continually
appropriated it would simply roll
forward and we could continue to use it
for the programs that were i'm sorry the
projects that were under construction
when it's not continually appropriated
my understanding is it just remains in
the renewable energy fund
but we are not able to use it
follow up mr chairman go ahead follow up
so i'm a little confused
you're saying it remains in the energy
fund but you can't use it so does that
mean we're having a some kind of an
unusable balance building up in this
fund year after year that just sits
without the continually appropriated
language yes that is correct
one more follow-up please
yes one more uh well what's the what's
the balance of this unavailable funds
that are sitting in the renewable energy
fund that we can't use right now
i i i'm sorry i don't have that figure
okay well i would hopefully someone
could get it for us because i think
that's kind of important if it's zero
then we don't have a problem if it's a
hundred thousand dollars we do
it would become a problem year over year
so for example right now our programs
for this fiscal year were
roughly five million dollars
um
and
we still have
several million i'm not and this is why
i don't want to give you a number of
projects that we have approved for
development but those uh rebates and
grants have not yet been paid out
so it's that money is right there that
would be in jeopardy or would would
you know stay be on
not able to be spent
i'm sorry mr chairman one more follow-up
please
make it quick please i'll make it very
quick so where does the money go then
i'm so that's not what i'm not hearing
you can't be spending it this year can
you spend it next year or is it just
sitting in a fund some place getting
larger every year that's what i'm
confused about
correct my understanding is without the
words continually appropriated
any funding from this fiscal year that
was not spent
would
simply remain in the renewable energy
fund
okay thank you uh representative plett
is uh recognized for a question i do
think that
representative carrick has elicited me
from mrs crampton uh are we spending
okay hang on a second our representative
press next should be closer to the
microphone
did you bring that microphone over
please
not very well
not very well at all
no
no not much
why don't you say a little more so
establish what you can hear you
how about now
better
i think you sound great
thank you uh
representative harrington may have
already elicited the response from uh
miss crampton uh to my question but i'll
ask it a different way to make certain
uh is less money being spent
than is
available in the renewable energy fund
because it's uh it's not continuously
appropriate
ms grampton
i i think the answer to that would be
yes i mean what ends up happening is you
have projects that have requested
funding that you are then no longer to
able to provide that funding for those
projects
so
yeah every fiscal year if there's a
balance it would remain in the renewable
okay thank
you i'm going to recognize
representative mcgee
and then we're going to have to move on
because we still have
other people who want to testify on this
bill and we're near the end of our
our time slot so
representative mcgee could you ask a
quick question please i could do that
thank you mr chairman
yes i was just wondering this is a has
an fn on it and it basically says under
the fiscal note that the legislative
budget office was unable to complete the
physical note for the bill and was
awaiting additional information from the
puc so i'm suspecting that maybe some of
the answers to the questions around
uh the monetary piece are still to come
[Music]
in terms of how much is left over and
not spent but i guess my question would
be
to the point that senator bradley made
around
the sort of consistency of people being
able to rely on funding through this
fund
so
um are we
are we um
[Music]
turning peop turning projects away or
to the fits and starts comment are we
funding them to a certain point and then
not providing the funding to complete
those projects like are there other
projects that are pulled up short that
are expected to go is that the kind of
inconsistency that is happening if we
don't
ms crampton
yes thank you for the question
yes so what would happen is if for
example if i put in an application
today to construct a project a solar
system for example on my business or my
home
if i didn't complete that project and
request a
rebate to the commission by june
i would no longer have funding for that
project available
so if i didn't if the commission
couldn't pay or treasury could not re
pay my rebate by july 1st
that that promise of funding
so to speak for my eligible project
would not be available to be paid out of
this fiscal year's monies
those monies would in a sense
no longer be available and the
commission would have to decide then
whether or not they would use next
fiscal year's monies to
um
incentivize projects from this fiscal
year so that's where that continual
the continuity and the fits and starts
that's one of the places that that
happens follow up mr chairman make it
quick please
yep um just curious um
so does this limit the public utility
commission's ability to use the funds
uh in the manner in which they were
intended
is crap then yes they can well if with
the addition of the continually
appropriated and non-lapsing language it
enables the commission to more
effectively and efficient efficiently
utilize the funds
and and and administer the programs
without those two words it's more
complicated
because we we
have to spend the money within a fiscal
year
okay thank you thank you that's crampton
we got to move on so i'm going to
recognize ms madeleine manneau for her
testimony ms minnow unfortunately can i
can only give you two minutes okay i'll
try to be quick thank you so much i'm
madeline the executive director of clean
energy new hampshire and i would urge
you to vote ought to pass on this bill
as senator bradley did a good job of
explaining this is very necessary
i'm so sorry about my dog
because of um
having the ability for having the
commission the ability to use the funds
that are available in the renewable
energy fund to use it for the intended
purpose of making grant and rebates so
the example i'm going to give you right
now is that the legislative change
removing continually appropriated was
done in 2017 however the commission did
not start
applying that until this fiscal year
and so they switched over how the fund
is managed
this year there was a tremendous delay
in setting the budgets for this fiscal
year that caused a very long disruption
and uncertainty
and then at the end of the last fiscal
year my understanding was there was
roughly two and a half million dollars
left in the fund
the commission now does not have the
authority to use that balance in the
fund for its intended purpose to make
grant rebates
right now
the residential solar rebate program is
out of funding for this fiscal year
even though there's a balance in the
fund
because the commission does not have the
authority to use the money in the fund
to fund the rebate program so they're
currently putting people on a waitlist
or turning them away from applying for
this rebate which is what this money was
intended to use for
while there's a there well there's money
in there also as has been explained
there's a huge disruption from one state
fiscal year to the next
um if you apply for rebate in may
you won't be able to finish your project
before the end of the state fiscal year
so you're probably going to be put on a
long wait list until the next
state fiscal year budgets are set to be
able to decide whether or not you are
eligible to be to receive a rebate so we
are asking that this be
changed back to continually appropriated
so that the state can better serve
customers that apply for a rebate or
grant program so that there's not such a
big disruption from one state fiscal
year to the next and that if there is
money available in the fund it can be
used for its intended purpose
thank you and i'm happy to take
questions
thank you ms minnow representative
sampson is recognized for a question
make it quick please yes thank you mr
chairman thank you miss minnow
would this bill also then allow the
current surplus of which you spoke to be
used for those purposes as well yes my
understanding is that if you all make
the fund continually appropriated again
the commission has the authority to use
any funds in the renewable energy fund
to fund the grant and rebate programs uh
that it's the intended use
thank you
okay thank you very much i think we have
the committee has a clear picture of the
intent of this bill
so i am going to close the public
hearing on senate bill 78
and i am going to open the public
hearing on senate bill 91.
now we have 18 people who have signed up
to testify on
bill 91 and what i would like to do
is i would like uh
people to
speak only on that part of the bill
to which they have a particular interest
or they have
particular expertise
so i'm going to recognize first senator
bradley as the prime sponsor to
uh introduce the bill senator bradley
uh
thank you very much i think senator
waters is also the sponsor but
um let me just touch on very briefly
section
two four and five
section two
deals with a particular application
of
hydroelectric facilities owned by
monadnock paper
in bennington new hampshire they're all
behind the meter as i understand it and
they are all under
um one megawatt and so they would
qualify
to be able to net meter but um because
of the fact that um
the rules by the public utilities
commission assume that they are greater
in total
the of the one megawatt
that is currently allowed by law they
have not been able to utilize the net
metering law that should apply to them
because there are three independently
licensed hydroelectric facilities so
this legislation
fixes that and my understanding is it is
only particular to that facility of
monadnock paper
um i'm going to allow
former commissioner and former senator
clifton below
to
talk about section 4 of the bill that
deals with
limited electrical producers and lastly
on section 5 as i understand that
senator avard may not be able to testify
he was
the sponsor of that piece
my understanding is representative vos
mr chairman that um you have put
together a really good compromise that
brought in
all of the parties on
um aggregation
on house bill 315 which the senate has
and so we're pleased with that
and i think um house bill 315
probably is the best way to proceed
on the compromise that you have put
together so
happy to answer any questions um
but
let me stop there
thank you senator bradley i appreciate
that
i would urge the committee to
withhold questions as much as possible
so that we have a chance to get through
this long list of people who want to
testify
i'm next going to recognize
senator david waters
and senator waters will speak
specifically to
section one
senator waters are you there i am there
and thank you mr chairman do you hear me
now i can thank you sir
thank you so much mr chairman and
members of the
committee um i am senator david waters
district 4 and as as prime sponsor of
the of senate bill 91 let me just
mention that um
this came from the senate with an
anonymous vote of the energy committee
and uh 23 to
one on the floor um one member who was
upset that we took out
one section of the bill to make it more
uh bipartisan
um part one deals with energy
storage as you know from your
deliberations last year this is an
increasingly active area
a home of business owners and investors
looking for clarity and fairness in
regulation
the bill is meant to work in tandem with
house bill 715 which you passed
last year to set up a study by puc
on this matter but we need um this bill
to set clear legislative intent and
principles so the puc
regulators are not setting policy but
the legislature is as it
as it should
um as you can see from the bill it's
it's really about economic development
letting people get invested in this
in storage it's about consumer choice
property rights
and really taking advantage of storage
potentially to lower
energy costs and also a needed
clarification
that energy storage is not counted as
generation for the purposes of sale into
the wholesale
market i want to thank you mr chairman
for your
suggestions
and advice on some changes here and i
look forward to the committees
pitching in to to make this better as
you
um see fit
so to get to the bill itself um this
bill replaces the existed existing rsa
h
so there are some rewritings and
re-inclusions of what is currently
in there
this is why the bill starts with a set
of definitions
these are essentially the same
definitions that already exist in 370
for
h
there are a couple of changes that i
will
go over
um on page 1 lines 30 to 31
uh it basically says you know if if the
puc finds that there are savings
due to storage they ought to account for
that in their um
rate setting
um and that's in section two
and then excuse me definition four
um
that it specifies that um anything we're
doing about storage
um is still the utilities do is still
regulated by 374 g1 so this does nothing
to
undo the uh or recouple the uncoupling
that was done
um previous uh previously
um to get to
the new section then on page 2
374 h2
um i'll first point to uh
section
of part 1 1b there on consumer
rights um
it's very important here to recognize
that you know you have a right to do
what you want to do with your property
and if you want to have energy storage
in your property or in business you
ought to not be over regulated or
prohibited from doing that
in a reasonable way
i know the um mr chairman in one see
here where we want to ensure that
the
that there is reasonable and timely um
regulation
uh you have concerns about the words
affordable because you know what is
what how do you define affordable and uh
point well made so i i do agree with you
that perhaps that word affordable
should be
cut
and then um on parts uh d d and e here
um this tries to get at the uh kind of
question of whether or not we will see
savings to transmission
costs
in in these programs and um there's some
dispute over this as as you well know
between the utilities and iso new
england
about new hampshire's share
among the states and its percentage of
share
due to transmission costs and the amount
of energy and it just seems fair that if
indeed there are
reductions to new hampshire's share
because we're reducing the amount of
energy draw because of storage
that that ought to be accounted for
i know you've heard from iso new england
that they don't really see this
you may hear a little bit later on from
the utilities that they do
but the bill itself is agnostic on that
it doesn't say that they are there
aren't it just says if there are that
that ought to be
um accounted for
uh going down a little further in the
bill the section here h3
uh essentially reproduces um section h
what was section 82 and 374. so this is
nothing new it's just because it's a
repeal and replace this is there this is
the study that you approved
last year
and uh the intent of of this bill senate
bill 91 part one is to work in tandem
with this that say as the results of
that study and what comes with that come
forward
then here are the guidelines from the
legislature as to how storage
should be and those results should be
under
understood and again i just want to
reiterate how important i think it is
um that the puc not set policy but
that's what the that's what the
legislative branch
um is supposed to
supposed to do
um and then like to go down to um 374
uh g2
um
and uh here's where we get into that
question of how we're going to
um what how we're going to consider
electric uh generation equipment and uh
and uh primary energy and energy um
storage
um equipment
and um
you know i i think there's lots of ways
to slice and dice this mr chairman and i
i know
you know you
your point is well taken that of course
when a battery produces energy it's
bruising it's producing energy and uh
and and i you know fair enough um so i
what i would hope here
is that um the committee might find some
languages satisfied uh with that just
essentially
um clarifies that storage is not counted
as generation for the purposes of sale
into the wholesale market
because that that that's the way we're
going to save money and
that's really the point of of all of
this
you also see online 30 on this page
a reference to benefiting low-income
customers this is kind of a principle
that's in other
parts of statute
of energy regulation it also reflects
the governor's often stated concern that
he wants to make sure that these new
technologies
can benefit low-income customers and as
you know advocates are interested in
that as well so that that's why that's
there um i don't think it's
much of a change beyond the current
practices that we already have elsewhere
but since it's a new chapter um it'd be
good to have it in here as well
then the last part here uh the end of
page four starting uh page five
is simply a way of acknowledging
the ongoing and liberty utilities uh
energy storage
project up in lebanon um so that it just
says that uh that that project is
acknowledged here and and allowed to
continue under the um
strictures and regulations that were
established for that project by the
puc
and finally let me just say uh mr
chairman that you know we know that uh
we're gonna be seeing an energy
department
and uh the puc will be
folded into that and i think that um you
know no matter how that uh that
department ends up and how those
functions end up being performed in the
energy department it's obvious there's
going to be puc-like functions and
regulation and dockets and
and so forth
so it's it seems uh here with this bill
that
it's it's just going to be essential
that uh that entity have the direction
and the legislative intent
on this uh burgeoning field of energy
storage
um i know there are a lot of other
people who are going to testify to more
details on this from the utilities and
others mr chairman but i'd be glad to
take any questions that you have
thank you senator waters does anyone
have a question for the senator
representative harrington is recognized
for a question i know short on time mr
chairman so i'll make this very quick
senator uh just as a matter of policy
from what we heard is that one section
of this bill is directed at a singular
company in new hampshire should we be
setting legislation to benefit a one
single company or should they adapt to
the existing rules
well thank you um
representative uh this um this project
uh has been approved is underway by the
puc
and um
so
it just seemed i mean it's underway
they're installing equipment and so on
and so i it just seems that um
you know it's kind of being
grandfathered essentially
so
moving forward of course it will be
subject in every other project
that it may wish to take by this
legislation
thank you senator
okay thank you i appreciate uh the
committee being um
and mrs chairman for the time being so
that we can get through the uh the rest
of the testimony and thank you senator
waters if i may mention mr chairman
senator avart asked that if you need me
to introduce section 5 because he can't
be here i will but based on what mr
senator bradley says if you don't need
me that's just as well
yes if you would
be willing to wave off on that i think
we have a pretty good yeah thank you
thank you mr chairman thank you
all right next up i would like to
recognize
donna gamash from
eversource energy to give us her take on
good morning thank you very much i will
be very brief i know you have a lot of
other folks who want to speak on this um
and i'm only going to speak on one
section eversource is neutral on this
bill
and the only reason that i've chosen um
one particular section to speak on is
only because we have some questions and
that is part four
and um part four is section four is the
host is the wholesale interest a concept
section
and for us um we are i mean we've shared
this with others that um we don't know
if or how it could be accomplished um
we're not sure how to separate
transmission out of distribution we're
not sure if without other changes in law
that it would be legal and um as is we
fear that the language would be inviting
disagreements between generators buyers
and utilities which we would prefer to
avoid um generally speaking um if this
committee is going to have some work
sessions we'd be very happy to work with
the committee and see if there is some
language that we could come up with that
would kind of address our concerns but i
i just wanted to be on the record that
we have some concerns with the language
as is on section four and that's all i
have this morning thank you
thank you many questions for uh ms
gamache
seeing none i will call next on
madeleine minow since uh we already have
her enabled to speak ms minnow why don't
you give your testimony now thank you
thank you so much mr chairman uh clean
energy new hampshire support senate bill
oh i would love to speak on every part
but i think that would be too long so
i'll try and be brief
we definitely support part one related
to energy storage i think senator waters
did a great job of introducing that
and why it's needed uh we support part
two it would clarify that hydroelectric
projects
that are individual however because of
the way they were originally constructed
are interconnected together should be
considered individually to decide
whether or not they are eligible for net
metering
and finally i will speak to part three
in a little bit more detail
the goal of part three would be to
effectively grandfather the low moderate
income community solar credit adder
which was created a couple of years ago
no projects have yet been constructed
that are eligible for
that adder and while we were going
through the rulemaking following the
legislation passing
all the developers said that it would be
much
more possible to finance such projects
if it was clear that the adder was
grandfathered on the same term that the
net metering credit is grandfathered so
that there's more certainty uh on the
continuation of the credit
going along with the net metering tariff
so that's the only thing that it's
trying to do it's not trying to change
what the adder is or make it last longer
or anything like that it's just trying
to really add more certainty around the
adder being available so that it might
be possible to finance such projects
with that i'll stop there we do uh
support the other parts i agree with
senator bradley that the last part
regarding community power likely that
can be handled through house bill 315.
okay thank you
uh seeing no questions for ms minnow i
would like to call on our next uh
testifier
with senator rebecca perkins quoca
senator you have the floor
thank you chairman and
thank you all good morning my name is
rebecca perkins cooka i'm the senator
representing district 21 the city of
portsmouth and
towns of madbury lee durham newington
newmarket and new fields um i was the
prime sponsor of what is now
part three
madeleine just covered some of it for
you but just
to have additional background you know
the purpose of this bill is the
clarification of the original language
um rsa 362 a9 um
originally intended to provide group
posts with a payment vehicle for excess
generation
such excess generation compensation rate
is determined using the tariff
applicable to such group hosts but in
addition there's an adder
of a determined amount as specified in
this section three cents per kilowatt
hour for a two year period dropping to
two point five cents per kilowatt hour
after that
so the new language just intends to
fix
in other words hold stagnant the amount
of the adder at the time the project is
qualified by the puc for group host
metering
as madeline mentioned this is important
to give certainty to those building and
financing
solar projects you know any construction
financing from a bank requires a pro
forma set of financials to verify debt
service ratios and other relevant
criteria to financing so it's important
for the project to have a fixed income
stream which this language helps create
the amendment to the section that was
made in senate energy and natural
resources was simply to accommodate a
concern raised by the puc about
some of the language and just making
sure that they'd be able to enforce it
cleanly
and i will stop there thank you mr
chairman and committee members for the
opportunity to testify happy to answer
thank you uh
i think we may have a question for you
senator uh
representative oxenom is recognized for
thank you very much mr chair for
recognizing me actually
and
with each of these presentations the
time available between when the person
stops talking and you ask if there are
any questions and then you say there
aren't any questions hasn't allowed me
to ask a single one of the questions
that i've wanted to ask this morning
um we we really don't need to be
operating at this breakneck speed i
think
you know
it's been such a pleasure to go to other
committees and testify where there is
deliberation and
a an opportunity for people to get their
head around what has been said to them
so that they can ask a question
um so at this point
i i'm not prepared to ask
other than to ask senator quoca if she
could explain the
the reason for the three cents and the
2.5 cents
what what what was the what criteria
were used in coming up with those
numbers
uh yes ma'am and respectfully
representative oxenham i may ask if
madeline minow can respond to that
particular question which may have been
who you intended to ask it to in the
first place um simply because that was
um
part of the original bill that was
passed uh in the years prior to my being
part of this process so if if you
wouldn't mind mr chair
you know no problem with me
yes i would be happy to answer um
when the bill that created the adder um
passed and was written the three cents
was i believe based on testimony from a
witness from the consumer advocate in
the net metering docket
de16575
or something like that the net meter the
last net metering docket
um there was consideration at the time
whether or not an adder should be
created for different reasons for this
type of project like the ones that serve
low moderate income um people or
dif projects in different locations so
there was discussion of adders
and i believe the three cents was
suggested by
some folks at vermont law school who
work on low moderate income community
solar it's also comparable to other
states that have similar programs
the step down to two and a half cents
was a negotiation
um i believe there's not really a
rationale for that other than um it was
more acceptable to pass the adder if
there was a step down after two years
as i mentioned no projects have been
constructed yet so no one at this point
would get the three cents if a project
was constructed it would go into service
okay thank you representative
representative samsic is recognized for
a question
thank you mr chairman and
thank you senator akoka um if i
understood correctly the motivation of
your portion of this bill is that you'd
like to streamline the business projects
uh from what what is going on now and
make that make these projects much more
predictable for everyone
is that the main motivation
yes sir exactly um and thanks for the
question so the intent is that there's
clarity for those who are proponents of
renewable energy projects in their
finance years yep
thank you
thank you okay thank you
see no more questions for senator
perkins cuoco we will move on to our
next speaker and i will recognize heidi
crowe
ms crowley you have the floor for
three minutes
good morning mr chairman thank you very
much um for the record my name is heidi
kroll i work at gallagher callahan
gartrell and i'm
testifying today on behalf of two
clients that i have the granite state
hydropower association
and otherwise referred to as gsha and
monadnock paper mills um as you know
gsha is a voluntary
non-profit trade association for the
small hydro
industry in new hampshire monadnock
paper mills is a family-owned business
located in bennington in new hampshire
it's the oldest continuously operating
paper mill in the country dating back to
1819 and the mill provides over 140
good-paying jobs in the monadnock region
um both clients support part two and
part four um and urge this committee to
pass on both of those parts part two and
part four of sb 91
furthermore we support the removal of
part 5 of the bill relative to the
aggregation community aggregation
i'll briefly explain other reasons for
these positions
first we support part two of the bill
because it will remedy a unique and rare
problem that monadnock paper mills
currently faces the problem is that
their three hydroelectric generators
which they use to help power the mill
share a single interconnection point
with the electric grid
and therefore they have not been able or
allowed to participate in net metering
even though each hydro unit is under one
megawatt and each is recognized by ferc
and the new hampshire puc
as an individually licensed facility
part two will simply clarify that the
small scale hydro facilities at mononok
paper mills are eligible to participate
in net metering as customer generators
based on their individual total peak
generating capacity
and should not be prohibited from
participating simply because they share
a single interconnection point with the
grid
um part two of sb 91 you know rectifies
this problem and we respectfully request
passage of it
i would also note that i did reach out
to the puc and eversource about part two
when sb 91 was in the senate and um
after both uh checked internally they
both told me that they did not see any
problems um or concerns
and certainly no problems understanding
or implementing part two
we also support uh support part four of
the bill which makes long overdue
updates to new hampshire's limited
electrical energy producers act known as
lipa
part four will finally enable local
buyers and local sellers of renewable
power in new hampshire to enter into
mutually agreeable power sale contracts
while protections are in place for those
rate payers who are not party to the
contracts
we would be happy to work with committee
if it feels that part four needs any
further work um or amendments
um
and part of the problem with the leipa
statute currently is that has never been
used so it's we would certainly um
welcome the opportunity to make that uh
usable um finally with respect to part
five um we understand that house bill
315 is the preferred vehicle um and so
part five of sb 91 does not um seem
necessary so uh we would support uh
removing part five and with that mr
chairman uh concludes my testimony and
i'd be happy to take any questions
thank you very much miss crowe any
okay
i'll call next on john gage
and
john gage's member of the public
representative representing himself
supports this bill mr gage you have
exactly three minutes
i won't need that long thank you
chairman for taking my testimony i
signed up to
testify on an item in section 5 that
senator watters has addressed
so i'm done thank you very much
next
i will call on samuel
golding
who
is a member of the public representing
himself mr bulgo golding you have the
floor for
two minutes
thank you chairman bows can you hear me
yes we can hear you
oh great
um so the big picture here in my view is
that the electricity market is somewhat
unique in terms of how big a role the
government has in terms of
directly setting the rules of the market
and as we all know the legislative and
rule making process invariably lags
behind the pace that technology and
consumer preferences change
so whenever that happens and it happens
all the time
we find ourselves in these situations
where the ways that market rules are
written
doesn't actually allow people in the
market to use the best technologies make
the best decisions and ultimately save
the most money they could be saving
so it falls to the legislature to
modernize the rules and that's what
parts one and four in particular of
senate bill 91 does
cliff below of lebanon can speak more
than this but the high level context is
that in-state generation and battery
storage
decreases the power we have to buy and
import from out of state using the
transmission grid
but right now the rules are set up so
that transmission grid charges are still
levied on electricity procured from
these local producers
and obviously
charging people for things they aren't
using makes no sense but in this case
it's a pretty big deal it's an unfair
tax essentially that averages 25
megawatt hour and could actually be
worth a lot more to batteries and other
technologies that can intelligently
dispatch power by targeting those peak
hours 30 seconds um
okay so
uh senate bill 91 modernizes
the rules it removes the price
distortion provides the clean price
signal and fixes the market for projects
across new hampshire i think it'll be a
shot in the arm for project construction
and i would hope that every
representative would support these
common sense pro new hampshire market
reforms
lastly just in response to concerns
raised i just want to say that whenever
you modernize the rules business as
usual does have to change market
participants utilities the puc have to
think it through and implement it
but that's just that's not an
argument for delaying the passage of
reforms all it means is we have to do a
bit of work on the back end to
implement more modern market rules thank
you very much thank you mr golding i
appreciate it
any questions for mr goldberg
seeing none i will call on next speaker
the next speaker is henry erndon
mr hermann the floor is yours for three
minutes
hello chairman can you hear me
i can
hello members of the committee my name
is henry herndon i'm an energy
professional here in the state
um and i really first got involved with
this committee during the house bill 315
effort and i was very pleased uh to see
the strong collaborative process to put
forward good common sense market-based
energy policy that was uh that was
really bipartisan and really
appreciative of your leadership uh
chairman votes on that and in that vein
just that briefly i'll speak in support
of senate bill 91 particularly part four
uh the previous speaker touched upon a
couple of the issues i wanted to address
but
so i'll be brief but i'll just boil this
down to say that
the benefits of this bill are creating a
market-based approach that avoids any
possibility of subsidy
for communities to build uh and benefit
from energy projects and storage here in
the state there's currently not a
mechanism there's clearly a lot of
demand uh we see that with the net
metering fights over the past three
years that's a policy that we haven't
come to agreement on and this really is
a way to
create a mechanism for communities to
benefit from development of solar and
storage in their communities and
reduce costs in that sense i'm not
surprised to hear um eversource sort of
you know casting a little bit of doubt
on this bill because as we've discussed
this is going to reduce transmission
costs for communities because we'll
alleviate their reliance on the
transmission grid and enable them to
lower their transmission costs um so so
um i don't think we should sort of let
that distract us from the benefits of
local economic development lowering
costs and really creating markets for
communities so i encourage all of you to
support senate bill 91 and i would be
happy to answer any questions if any
members of the committee have questions
thank you
mr herndon
representative harrington is recognized
for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh
if you can be as specific as possible
could you please tell us
how this is going to save transmission
costs
yes it's a good question thank you um
representative
so when a generator connects to the
distribution grid
and sells power to a purchaser locally
say a community power program say for
example the city of nashua wants to buy
power from its hydro dams and supply
that to its residents and businesses
through a community power aggregation
that power does not
interface with the transmission grid at
the wholesale level because it's under
five megawatts and if that generator is
registered at under 5 megawatts it's not
registered it doesn't have to be
registered in the wholesale market now
in particular if that generator is
producing electricity during the monthly
peak hour then that electricity is
reducing the transmission peak for that
month and transmission peaks are set
monthly so if you have a generator in
nashua providing power locally to its
residents and businesses
during the monthly peak that is that is
directly lowering transmission peaks
directly lowering transmission costs and
the language in second part four of this
bill
uh would ensure that if that's measured
if it's actually measured that during
that same time we're reducing
transmission costs then the the people
paying for that power wouldn't have to
pay for those transmission costs i hope
that gets at your question
thank you it was a very uh precise and
thank you
representative harrington for the
question
representative occident i'm trying to
give you uh time to formulate a question
are you okay
well thank you very much sir i really
appreciate that i you know i i really
try to listen to the speaker and and not
come in with a pre-formulated question i
very much appreciate that description of
of how the peak
reduction and the peak pricing
translates into those reduced costs that
was really useful i thought i had a
question but
henry really took it out from under me
so um thank you very much and and thank
you for the opportunity
okay thank you
uh representative mcgee has a question
go ahead and try to make it quick and
brief representative
thank you mr chairman
you don't have to say it every time i
understand
um
you opened uh mr herndon
mentioning a market-based approach and
you also made reference to the fact that
there would be no subsidy and i think
that that is a recurring theme with
bills that we hear in our committee so
could you say a little bit more about
how
section 4 does not contribute in any way
to uh subsidies
yeah i can speak to that um so the
reason i use that language is because
this would allow for just a bilateral
negotiated contract so the price would
be set by whatever the agreed upon terms
are between the generator or the seller
and the the customer the buyer who could
be a large energy user or it could be a
community power program so because it is
a negotiated contract price it's not a
rate that's set by regulators or by the
state and what we get in net metering
is a rate that is set by regulators and
there is disagreement on the values and
the benefits associated with net
metering there are studies that show
that you know all this distributed
generation out on the grid it's it's
doing just that same concept of load
reduction and it's suppressing wholesale
market prices and suppressing
transmission costs
so there's value there but then there's
disagreements on on sort of uh the
distribution credit and other assets so
so just essentially the difference here
is this is purely a negotiated price on
that metering i you know we won't get
into that debate there but there's there
is a debate on the values and benefits
of net metering as it is a rate set by
thank you
thank you representative mcgee
representative samson is recognized for
a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
hearn
uh as a energy analyst
how do you define the difference between
uh that that's
the difference between battery storage
and energy generation one is producing
power the other is is simply storing up
power and then providing it to the grid
and they can perform similar types of
services
but importantly this build would remove
barriers to battery storage and there's
a lot of benefit there because as we
know
some of the most developable resources
are things like solar in the state but
solar is an intermittent resource and if
you compare that with energy storage you
can maybe really target your solar power
to make sure you're hitting for example
peak time usage so you soak you fill up
your battery in the middle of the day
with your with your cheap solar power
and then when that uh evening ramp comes
along and and uh the solar power
generation falls off
um that creates an opportunity to put
that power back on the grid from the
battery and that's really how you're
going to ensure you're measuring
that power is going on to the grid
during the transmission peak or during
the capacity peak so it's so you can
measure that it's reducing those costs
and pass all of those savings on to the
residents and businesses and communities
in new hampshire
follow up mr chairman
follow up
so mr hernan would you agree with me
that a battery storage
unit would be a generator if if more
energy came out of it than you put into
it
i would not agree that a battery storage
project would be a generator i would say
that battery storage could be paired
with generation and work
synchronistically with it
thank you
okay thank you uh
mr herndon i have a question for you
can you explain to the committee
why
this
uh
the approach to buying and selling
energy as suggested by this legislation
is superior to
the current
system whereby
buyers and sellers of electricity can
it's a good question i'll give it a shot
i'm not sure that i can answer you but
my understanding is that this so uh this
particular legislation it's it's
addressing the limited producers uh
piece of law and i'm forgetting the
exact the exact rsa reference um
but the existing i don't know exactly
the details of why that existing law is
not functional but it has to to date not
been used and um it is constructed in
such a way that that prevents the market
from being able to make use of it so the
purpose of this bill
part 4
is to correct those imperfections and
ensure that we can actually have a
marketplace in the state and we can
allow large energy users and communities
to to benefit from local generation as
opposed to being sort of trapped in the
in a
a system that requires them to pay for
imported power from out of state
it doesn't answer your question about
the power purchase agreement directly um
i apologize for that
that's quite all right
you did your best i appreciate it
uh are there any other questions from
the committee
seeing none before i call on the next
speaker i just want to
assure the committee that
the last speaker of the day on this bill
will be
clifton below and he is intimately
familiar with the details of
many if not all of the sections of this
bill so
he will get plenty of time to speak
and there will be plenty of time to
ask him questions
afterwards
so now i'll call on the next speaker who
is katherine corkery representing the
new hampshire sierra club
hello hello good morning uh and thank
you so much for having me uh it's good
to see you chairman and the rest of the
committee this is katherine corkery i'm
the chapter director of new hampshire
sierra club
and i am
registering support for this bill
um
and really the the only concerns that i
had have already been brought up um and
that is the proposal
of the department of energy
uh and the role that it could play
uh in this bill and in the previous bill
um
i'm not sure if this committee has
really discussed the proposal
for the department of energy because it
was in the budget
um but i i just wanted to
voice my concern for that
and secondly
the other concern that has already been
addressed
is your bill hb 315 and
making way for for that bill to progress
um so with that i i
will summarize uh
my support uh the sierra club support
for
uh sb
thank you very much we appreciate you
being here to testify any questions for
seeing none i'll call on our next
speaker
who is joseph kwasnik
mr kwosnik is a member of the public
here
supporting uh
represented himself representing himself
rather and he supports the bill mr
kwosnik the floor is yours for two
minutes
uh mr chairman thank you very much for
allowing me to testify today and thank
you for the committee for providing the
time to do so i'll keep my comments
short i am today submitting written
testimony in support of house excuse me
senate bill 91
parts one through four an amendment of
senate bill 191 part five if part five
is not amended it should be removed from
the legislation
and house bill 315 should be the
preferred vehicle to deal with community
power
also sb 91 represents the only remaining
active bill in the new hampshire
legislature that provides any positive
modification to the current net metering
provisions
and expands local electric power project
developed in new hampshire
this bill is good for the cities and
towns of new hampshire it provides
opportunity to lower electric costs to
consumers
and makes new hampshire more
economically competitive with the other
new england states they have already
adopted legislation similar to
senate bill 91
this bill is amended ought to pass it is
in the best interest of new hampshire
electric customers and like house bill
315 enjoys us overwhelming support from
new hampshire voters please do not
disappoint new hampshire voters by
finding this bill in expedient to
legislate
and that concludes my testimony thank
you mr chairman
see none
i'll call on our next speaker
who is kim
quirk
and i think
ms quirk i believe
as a member of the public representing
herself mrs cork you have the floor for
two minutes
thank you chairman vos and the entire
committee for your work on this bill and
and many others knowing that uh cliff
below will be coming later i can keep my
testimony very short and hopefully give
him time for all sorts of questions i'm
in support of this bill
with an amendment or elimination of part
five i've been an active community
member in enfield on the energy
committee we are also interested in
community power
in our town and i'm also a
co-owner and employee of revision energy
so i've been in the solar energy field
for a lot of years i feel very strongly
that we must do what we can to reduce
and eliminate fossil fuels as quickly as
possible and address the many issues
that have resulted from
from their use
sb 91 includes important articles that
would support
increased renewables and distributed
storage which i think is something we
absolutely have to address and community
power programs also of course extending
the low and moderate income
pieces to that is also extremely
important i think so thank you again for
your work on this bill and
we hope to make new hampshire uh have a
thank you miss quirk we appreciate your
testimony
seeing none and i will turn to our next
speaker who is mark
vader
and he did not originally sign up to
speak but he had his hand raised so i'll
allow mr batter to speak thank you mr
chairman um
i uh
was just looking at the text for sb 91
on um
in in section four
subsection
um six
it says
purchasers of power from limited
producers shall pay for the delivery of
such power through tariffs charges and
rates that are generally applicable to
the customer's rate class
and to me that does not sound like a
purely negotiated rate
i'm just wondering if we have our facts
wrong
okay that's a legitimate question
i'm going to suggest that we ask that of
clifton below when he testifies
would that be satisfactory to you mr
batter very very good thank you
i believe
that we are out of speakers
who will be
clifton below
okay
so clifton below
former puc commissioner former state
representative former state senator
uh mr biela you have the floor and i'm
going to give you more time than usual
because i know you have extensive
information to provide about this bill
and we'll have
plenty of time to ask you questions
so i hope you heard mr vader's question
a few moments ago and if so that you can
incorporate that into your testimony and
answer to that question
and i now ask you to take it away
good morning mr chairman um members of
the committee thank you for the
opportunity uh to testify on
senate bill 91. um i'll just go ahead
and answer that uh question that was
just raised
just to to uh before i forget um and it
was a question it's on page seven lines
29 to 32
and it says purchases a power from
limited producers shall pay the deliver
for the delivery of such power through
you know the normal tariffs the delivery
of the power it would be the
distribution rate um that is applicable
to the customer so that is not
negotiated that is set by the puc it is
a separate charge then the power itself
the generation of the power um so in in
the current um rsa 362 a 2a
there is a provision that talks about
having wheeling charges um apply
that language goes back to 1979 before
there was open access to transmission or
customer choice any choice of uh
generation supply
so it's really that is really an
antiquated part of the current statute
uh that instead recognizes that um
even if the power plant is right next
door um
but you're using the distribution lines
of the distribution utility you would
still pay the normal distribution rate
so that's what that's about
so let me back up to the big picture um
here
um
i would note that it was
some 20
um
three years ago
in 1970
when i was serving on this committee
that i sponsored i was the prime sponsor
of the bill that originally created net
metering uh then representative bradley
then the chair of this committee uh was
was my co-sponsor on that bill
and we actually worked through a great
many work sessions on the bill that
created net metering it also revised rsa
362 a 2a
to a limited extent and made other
revisions to the overall limited
producer statute that eliminated the
requirement for the utilities themselves
to purchase power
from limited producers
because it was sort of recognized as
predator restructuring it really wasn't
the utility necessarily to be purchasing
um output from limited producers uh
called qualifying facilities under the
that
new hampshire's limited producer statute
was a forerunner too um in any case
um as part of that um we did state at
the time um
as part of the purpose section of the
statute that we thought net metering
was one way that customers could have
access to a choice of
renewable generation but that it was
also
intended primarily for early adopters
uh and
and that language about it being for
early adopters was subsequently um
removed by the statute in in more recent
years um
but quite honestly i never really
imagined that net metering would grow to
the point where people were looking at
uh two three four wanting to have four
megawatt size projects um participate in
that metering because at that point you
know it's really all about group net
metering even a lot of the projects
between 100 kw and 1 megawatt are about
group net metering which is essentially
one at one site you're producing the
power and other uh customers and the
customers or the off takers to that
power supply um so part four of the bill
is an effort to um
uh
modernize that existing statute uh that
enables a limited producer to sell
either at retail or uh within the state
to a supplier
at essentially a wholesale uh
transaction within the state
um
and and to you know put some context on
this this this i see part four the bill
as a real compliment to what um house
bill 315 does in enabling community
power aggregations
here in lebanon as we've tried to
develop the concept of lebanon community
power we have talked with a number of
businesses and institutions who've been
very interested in the idea of being
able to purchase power through a
purchase power agreement from a local
renewable
source
and at the same time we've actually been
approached by a couple of property
owners who own sites that are suitable
for
uh solar projects that might be in the
one to five megawatt range
and they don't want to just you know
they their thought is they would like to
use their land to benefit the community
and so they
and one of these landowners we had a
conversation with a year two ago just
called me up um on friday to ask um that
he'd still like to see his land use for
a large-scale solar project and would
really like to be able to sell that
through lebanon community power
to local uh residents or businesses
um and at the same time um just a couple
weeks ago i was also approached by a
major developer in in this area a check
clem of uh lime properties which has
been working to develop a 38 acre site
in west lebanon that has already
received um
necessary zoning changes as well as site
plan approval for up to 850
000 square feet of mixed use but
primarily um offices uh particularly
targeting the biotech industry um he has
found that a lot of his potential um
tenants
and he started construction in the first
building on this site are interested
they have sustainability goals and
they're very interested in the idea of
being able to purchase local renewable
energy
the sort of uh under one megawatt
groupnet metering you know might work a
little bit in some
applications
but really
more scale is needed
so right now we have a situation where
under one megawatt can participate in
net metering
anything that's five megawatts or larger
is required to participate in the iso
new england markets
those are the interstate power markets
for bulk power supply and it's generally
accepted that larger than five megawatts
or even smaller if you're connected
directly to the transmission grid is uh
the size that it should be considered
producing in interstate commerce that
puts it under first jurisdiction in the
rules of iso new
england at the same time
though going back to the federal power
act that was enacted in the 1930s
congress made very clear that ferc's
jurisdiction is limited to
a transmission in interstate commerce
and um
in with regard to energy markets and
power supply sales at wholesale
uh to another purchaser is going to
resell it
in interstate commerce
and that's a clearly defined term in the
federal statute um
that that is uh i cited in my written
testimony which you probably haven't
haven't had a chance to look at because
i just emailed it to you earlier this
morning but i have provided written
testimony that provides a lot of these
details
interstate uh commerce as
a situation where energy um
that is uh generated in one state is
transmitted from a state and consumed at
any point outside thereof
and uh and so the authority of the ferc
does not extend to sales of electricity
in what is called intra-state within the
state wholesale commerce or at retail
um so new hampshire law has long sort of
recognized this sort of
regulatory opportunity if you will or
it's jurisdiction which is to say new
hampshire has jurisdiction over
generation and and storage as well
that is under five megawatts and is not
registered with iso new england as a
generation asset
it's worth noting that iso new england
um defines a generator asset as a device
that or collection of devices that's
capable of injecting real power onto the
grid and has been registered as a
generator asset uh in accordance with
the uh iso new england rules
um
so a battery
by that definition can be and is
considered a generator because it can
inject a real power into the grid and as
such um if they're five megawatts or
larger they need to register with new
england if they're going to be injecting
power into the grid even if connected to
the distribution grid but if they're
smaller than that they don't they don't
have to register with iso new england
so we kind of have a gap which is part
of what part one is trying to address is
the notion of distributed storage and by
distributor i mean connected to the
distribution grid under five megawatts
and and not participating in the first
jurisdictional interstate uh power
market if if you've got a generator that
um
or storage that meets that criteria
the only real option is net net metering
at the moment
um
and
that's why there's so much pressure to
expand net metering from one megawatt to
five megawatts
and i think the time has come that we
need to move away from net metering for
these large projects and look at a more
market-based approach that fairly
compensates those assets without by
trying to avoid cross subsidies so that
this is sustainable over the long term
on its own merits
and i've you know just given a couple
examples of potential buyers and sellers
within the city of lebanon who would
like to be able to do that um but but
it's difficult under current law
i have attached as part of my testimony
towards the end of it
is a copy of the current statute rsa 362
a 2a
and you can take a look at that and see
that it is somewhat archaic but it does
by its plain language enable a limited
producer to sell up to any three
customers whether they be at retail or
within state wholesale
um
up to three without
puc approval and more than three if you
went through a process to get puc
approval for more when this idea first
came up a couple years ago
we heard from the from pretty much
everyone we talked with including uh
utilities that there's no particular
reason to have that limit of three um so
part of what the new uh language does is
expand that uh to any number of of
customers that could be served by a
limited producer uh sort of like group
net metering exists today for up to one
megawatt there could be any number of
members of a group um
the you know i recognize that this
similar language came forward to the
committee as part of house bill 295
sponsored by representative pearl
and house bill 417 uh sponsored by
representative mcgee and both of those
bills i believe you voted in expedient
to legislate
and so the first explanation might be
well let's take this out and and just
you know
not have this part of the bill because
you've already taken a position on that
in talking with the chairman i i
realized that there were a number of
concerns that were raised about um this
some of this language that you didn't
really have time to adequately address
uh but i my hope is that you will take
the time now uh to consider this
um
part four of the bill and work let's try
to work with the stakeholders as we did
on house bill 315 to see if we can't
resolve concerns uh such as those that
miss gamache just raised on behalf of
eversource i have opened a dialogue uh
with with miss gamache
and eversource to try to understand
their concerns and try to address those
uh to some extent my testimony does
elaborate on on the jurisdictional
issues i think one really important one
that i that i'd like to call your
attention to
is is the fact that um traditionally net
meter generation
has not has functioned as a load reducer
relative to the iso new england markets
as well as for transmission cost
allocation i think you've heard this
before but i'll just reiterate
the way transmission cost allocation
works
is that um
the all the transmission owners figure
out their revenue requirements that goes
through an approval process so we have a
total revenue requirement
for transmission so an overall rate per
kw based on the projected uh
kw or megawatt demand uh on the system
is is projected and then those costs are
allocated over the course of the year
based on each month's
single hour of coincident peak
so you've got a monthly
hour of highest demand on the new
england system and that demand is what's
called regional network load and all
those transmission costs get allocated
to regional network load based on their
share that that total there's also
something called local network it sort
of parallels regionals so i'm not going
to explain that but but it's essentially
the same thing but for portions of the
transmission grid that only serve parts
of new england
so eversource and national grid own both
regional uh networks as well as what's
called local although the local just
means it's just serving a limited number
of distribution systems uh
in new england
so the regional network load is
basically the load as measured at the
meter that exists between the
first jurisdictional transmission grid
and the new hampshire jurisdictional
distribution grid
and so you measure that load
and then there's an adjustment so if you
have a bulk generator that's putting
their power onto the distribution grid a
generator say that's 10 megawatts um
then their output is not considered to
reduce
the distribution system load or the
retail load so you would add that
generation output at that hour of
coinstone peak demand to what is
measured at that
uh meter between the transmission grid
and the distribution grid but you
increase the regional network load by
the output of
generation assets those that are
registered with iso new england
and that is used for the allocation
but if generation
such as net meter generation that's not
registered with iso new england or
anything up to five megawatts that's not
registered with iso new england
if it reduces the load on the
distribution grid by essentially
directly serving it over the
distribution grid rather than requiring
the power to come in from trans over
transmission then it does in fact reduce
the regional network load there's been
some confusion about this about some of
the language and the tariff so over the
past year there's been a process at iso
new england to clarify that language
i did include a slide deck from a
presentation to the iso new england's
market committee that was made on behalf
of transmission owners including
eversource and national grid in which
the transmission owners have proposed a
clarifying definition
that says i'll just read it to you and
it is quoted again in my written
testimony network customers monthly
regional network loads shall exclude one
load offset by any resources that is not
a generator asset
meaning it's not registered with iso new
england which means it is by definition
under five megawatts
and two yeah
yes uh did you just say that what you're
reading is in your written testimony yes
i did
can i suggest that since we only have 20
minutes left okay
that you consider
allowing the committee to read your
written testimony
and maybe wrap up your writ your spoken
testimony now so that we'll have
adequate time for questions because i
know the committee has a lot of
questions for you so certainly i'll wrap
up in a minute or two here um so so
basically the clarification
would allow
um
these under five megawatts to function
as load reducers
both for the market purposes and for the
transmission charges
um having said that i do want to briefly
mention that i also suggest one a fairly
minor but but but substantive and impact
um amendment to part one of the bill um
which is just where there's a definition
of wholesale electricity markets
it means any energy capacity or
ancillary service market that iso new
england operates i suggest adding the
words or that may operate pursuant to
rsa 362 a 2a because the current
language in that statute does enable a
within state wholesale transaction and
it would more clearly allow that
if if the
language along the lines of part four
the bill were adopted the reason for
that is because
uh that definition is used in part one
of the bill to direct the commission to
investigate ways to enable energy
storage projects to receive compensation
for avoided transmission costs while
also participating in wholesale energy
markets
but i would submit that if they're
participating in the iso online energy
or capacity markets they will have no
effect on reducing transmission because
their output is added to regional
network load which which is how costs
are allocated
so if you simply also look at the option
of what happens if they aren't
registered with iso new england or small
enough that they could be selling uh
direct at retail or within state
wholesale then you may actually see the
realization of that value and finally
i'll just also mention that uh there's
another suggested amendment um in in my
uh testimony um
to add
to part four of the bill where it sets
criteria um that in order to qualify for
this limited producer within state sales
you can't also be participating in iso
new england ice nicer new england
markets and but isolation has created an
exception to that which is for
an alternative technology regulation
resource and you'll see in the slide
decks an illustration of how this new
tariff language would apply and if a
storage system was
only functioning as an alternative
technology
resource a regulation of regulation
resource then it would still function as
a load reducer for transmission cost
allocation and it's simply because
battery storage in particular is very
good at providing regulation services uh
with with what's called you know a smart
inverter um it can provide some of the
services that bug generators provide on
the transmission grid and there's sort
of there's been a determination in
iceland new england in the new pool
processes that would be okay to let
generation that's otherwise functioning
as a load reducer to provide that one
regulation resource without having to
register as a generator asset so i'll
stop there and open it to questions my
my hope is that you'll take this
opportunity uh you've got some time here
uh to take a closer look at this part
four and see if we can't improve upon
the language address concerns that uh
utilities or other stakeholders and
committee members may have and and try
to come up with something that that
really um
uh can can help solve this dilemma how
to best uh accommodate one to five
megawatt uh generation and battery
storage on our distribution grid thank
you
okay thank you mr bilo i knew that you
would provide us with
a
a hose full of uh information for us to
consume i have a couple of questions
on section one of the bill both you and
senator waters have mentioned
that there are weaknesses in the
legislation as passed by the senate
that need
some tweaking
so my question for you is before we
undertake that work
which could turn into a considerable
amount of
effort
what is the reason for passing this
legislation today in other words could
this legislation wait until next year
where it could be reworked to deal with
the issues that have been uh uncovered
um well of course you can always wait um
i think the
sort of urgency to it if you will
is
that
right now it's really unclear under what
conditions the customer can install
storage behind the meter
the commission has felt like they don't
have clear authority to allow it in its
part net metering as part of net
metering
um
so there is not really a recognition of
it as to how it can and should work um
on the distribution grid but having been
very involved with liberty utilities
battery pilot docket and supporting that
um liberty kind of
you know is using the same sort of value
proposition that i've described here
which is to say can we dispatch storage
um at a few hours per month to try to
target this uh peak hour of demand and
reduce that demand and thus produce
reduction in transmission cost
as well as capacity cost um because the
capacity in in the energy market for
capacity market is based on the annual
system peak and it is reduced by storage
or distributed generation uh that serves
as a load reducer
so
that you know liberty was able to
justify that in a regulatory setting but
we don't have the same mechanism in
place for customers to do this on their
own if you will
to do so
under some
some structure
that does regulate it but allows the
realization of the value of of that kind
of load reduction so i think that is
sort of the urgency to this combined
with the fact that every year we see
more and more variable renewable
generation on the system and storage
becomes increasingly important to help
balance that supply and demand in real
time
so that that's sort of a long answer to
a short question thank you mr chairman
okay thank you and as a follow-up
question i would ask on uh section four
of the bill
you've also cement uh mentioned some
possible amendments that are necessary
to
make that section of the bill
as useful as it can be
is it also true that uh
this legislation is necessary now to
allow projects to move forward
well two things if if you took this out
if you took part four out of the bill
and either or if you retain the bill
uh then you would be prohibited from
uh
in a committee report or a drafting
exercise
from bringing part four forward
uh because of um house rule i think it's
36e
that prohibits the same language or
substantially the same language as being
considered in the second year of the
session if it was itl buy the house in
the first year of the session and i
think because you've
already itl two similar bills you might
be prohibited from uh bringing this back
um next year um however that rule
doesn't apply to considering a senate
bill in the same session year as you may
have i t yelled it on a house bill
and so that's why i'm hoping you will
try to take the time to see if we can't
find some broader bipartisan agreement
that might enable it to move forward
this year
and also just in terms of planning even
once it's going to take some period of
time to actually work out the details
the puc may need to do some rule making
or department of energy maybe uh rule
making on this
um
and
so
to be blunt my concern is without
something like this that people can see
on the horizon here's an alternative to
develop some of these larger projects
we're just going to see after the next
election another big push to expand that
metering to five megawatts and my
concern is there's cross subsidies in
both directions under current net
metering terms um you know the large
projects over 100 kw get no credit for
reducing transmission cost even if they
do that but on the other hand so so
that's a you know a subsidy in one
direction that benefits other customers
uh but in in the direction of the
generator they're getting i think
overcompensated at the full retail price
um so
you know we need to unravel that and not
you know what happened in maine after
after they limited uh net metering for a
long time there was the legislature
changed and they did a huge expansion
and now they're facing huge numbers of
projects in the one to five megawatt
range that
are perhaps
you know
being overcompensated to put it bluntly
um if there was a bilateral deal on some
of those projects the terms might be
better for rate payers and
and now they're also looking at the big
question of are they created new
stranded costs that are being subsidized
i think we want to try to avoid that
okay good thank you for that
clarification representative mcgee is
recognized for a question thank you mr
chair
um this was an excellent though
voluminous
explanation but i think
what i heard you saying boiled down on
item one of this omnibus bill
is that sort of the last frontier
for us to address is figuring out that
sweet spot between one and five
megawatts of energy contributions that
are happening within the state and how
to value them appropriately and that
that section basically gives the public
gives them the reins to go look at that
and try and figure out how we do that
properly in order to assess the value of
storage capability within the state
for the value that it contributes is
that an accurate way of looking at what
you said
it is it is and i simply know that for a
long time
people even lawyers in the energy field
have often said well ferc and in iceland
new england have exclusive jurisdiction
over wholesale electricity sales
that's simply not true they have
exclusive jurisdiction over interstate
wholesale sales states have exclusive
over intro within states at wholesale
sales and if we don't create a framework
for it we're essentially saying you
can't do it and you have to
you have to you can only go up to the
iso new england level which isn't
necessarily the most beneficial for our
rate payers or those
local development opportunities
thank you and follow up mr chair
follow up
yep and the second thing that i
just heard you say was about the state
of maine and about
our continuing pursuit of trying to
figure out
how to just raise net metering caps as
as a way to address
um
that sweet spot between one and five
megawatts and you're saying that that
may not be the holy grail that we think
it is and that we by
by taking a further look through the
public utilities commission at how we
should be handling these
interstate
um
editions of distributed energy
and storage we might be able to come up
with a more
reasonable and market-based solution
exactly yes oh good good i'm glad
because you said so much and i was
trying to
put it in context thank you
thanks very much
representative plett is recognized for a
question
before i start am i close enough so you
can hear me
yes i can hear you okay uh thank you for
pointing out that sections one and four
need some work are you willing to
uh provide uh
input to make to make those sections
better than they currently are
yes very much so whatever time it takes
okay secondly uh thank you for
recognizing that there are cross
subsidies on the net metering as it
exists
can we work together to try to eliminate
those cross subsidies going forward yes
i would like to do that very much
because because in the long run i don't
okay thank you representative oxendine
representative oxenom you're recognizing
yes i'm here but i'm trying to
you know again
process what was just said which opens
up an enormous ball of wax and i think
what i need to do is set that aside and
continue with my first question
um
thank you very much mr bilo for your
continued willingness to to work with
our committee
uh i
i want to question your statement that
you don't or at least the implication of
your statement
that you don't think the energy storage
section needs
that there's any urgency here we've been
there there
this issue has been pushed back and
pushed back uh we have a puc docket
which is coming to resolution and in
fact part of the language that's
incorporated by the senate in this has
taken the the very good information that
has been brought forward in that
proceeding and says
let's take this out of the hands of the
puc as it were if if this is in
indeed policy setting
make sure that this is in fact what the
legislature wants to see happen and and
i believe that that we do have agreement
here by the senate and the house that
this is the way to proceed that we do
need the clarity
that
moving to rules making without a
subsequent period for writing reports
and getting back and reporting
that this is a real opportunity to do
something that is vitally important for
moving our
grid mod forward and getting the value
proposition recognized we're not going
to have developers producing
coming into the state investing creating
jobs if we don't have clear rules and
procedures for them to follow so i i'd
like to just question you on that issue
do you not see this as a sense
of urgency
i i completely agree that there's an
urgency to moving forward this um so i i
only just was acknowledging the factual
reality that it's always an option to
retain a bill and and
study it some more
but i think in this case a lot of work
has gone into part one of the bill and
uh that
whatever issues remain i would hope
could be resolved in the next month
before the committee has to report the
bill and move it forward
thank you very much
thank you uh representative callie pitts
still muted
i think rod was before me i'm just
uh
feminism
thank you chairman vos and it wouldn't
have mattered to me
uh who went first
but uh
getting getting on this timeline thing
my question to you uh
mr bilo is
um
if this went to
like a subcommittee
to work out these details do you feel
that we have a very good chance of
getting this uh
under the wire
and uh
and out of committee before
i believe so um i know
that my own utility i believe liberty is
is comfortable with with the current
language i know eversource has some
concerns i i think there's you know
after experience with 315 there there's
a newfound willingness to realize that
we can find common ground if we just
simply understand each other's concerns
a little bit better
so that would be my hope that we can we
can think this through and get everybody
okay thank you representative callie
pitts
cliff i was going to ask is is it do you
believe it's possible since these were
four different bills
parts of these bills
do not require
a lot of work and other sections do
do you believe it's possible to retain
pieces of this bill or do we have to
retain
the whole bill and then create a new
bill for the next
next session
um i i i
that's a i think this idea of omnibus
bills from the senate is is relatively
new so yeah
i think you're asking something that's
maybe never been answered before
um
it does seem
so i don't know the answer to it i don't
know whether you can retain it seems
like it's just strikes me as an all or
nothing either retain the whole bill
or
pass it with amendment
um and or stick amendments on other
related bills i don't know
okay
are there any other questions
we are just about out of time anyway
here so
um
i'd like to thank mr bilo for his
testimony
and since we exhausted our list of
testifiers i would like to
close this public hearing on senate bill
and
we will take a one-hour lunch break and
return here at one o'clock for a
presentation
on the
um
financing of renewable energy projects
um see you then chairman do we have a
blue sheet count
oh the blue sheet you're right um
so on senate bill 91 we had 20 283
people
who signed up in favor one opposed and
two were neutral
thank you
okay
all right everybody have a good lunch
i've just muted the room
represent branching you should be all
set
you are i'm not sure that i see all of
the speakers that were noted earlier
but miss minnow is connected to the call
okay i believe we're going to start with
ms minnow anyway
so
somehow
i'm here chairman rose i'm
one of the
panelists and on camera
you were hiding on me
sorry
okay so
uh
beyond the one o'clock uh
no it's just one o'clock now okay
right at one o'clock this clock in here
is four minutes fast
but uh we're ready to go so what we're
going to do this afternoon is we're
going to have a presentation from three
who will explain to us the intricacies
and the nuances
of financing renewable energy projects
so that we can understand exactly
what's involved in doing those projects
representative oxenom do you have your
hand up on purpose or was that a
necessity
i'm guessing
it was an accident
okay your hand is down so now we're
ready to go so
uh
representative sausage do you need to do
any introductory remarks uh about this
subject since you set up this
presentation
uh
no mr chairman i think i'll just let all
the speakers introduce themselves
uh i just wanted to uh thank them though
for coming to us
because we have heard a lot about
different types of financing of these
projects and it's good to hear from
agreed uh what order will we hear the
speakers mrs minov first and then
i believe it was uh mr clapp from
revision energy and then jeff
haydock uh was last
okay excellent
all right so we have uh a game plan here
so ms minnow why don't you excuse me i i
was able finally to unmute myself
i did have my hand up for a reason
before we begin
okay go ahead what is it thank you very
much there was discussion this morning
about the possibility of
moving forward on the builds this sp 91
is it
i i'd hate to see us go
you know off and and leave this up in
the air if time is of the essence
should we be discussing the possibility
well it was my plan to schedule a work
session on this bill
and at that time if we determined we
need a separate committee we can form
one would that be acceptable to you
i'm delighted to hear that that you
intend to have a work committee would we
be informed um as to who would be
involved uh perhaps by email
well as i just said we're going to have
a full committee work session first
and then if we decide we need a
subcommittee
we'll
decide who that subcommittee will be
during that work
session thank you very much okay thank
you
okay
are we finally ready now
i think so so ms minnow it's yours
great thank you so much for the
opportunity to speak with you today and
i look forward to
presenting this information to you as
well as any questions you may have
i did send representative some such an
outline of what i plan to cover today
and so you can use that as a guide i'll
just be providing a little bit more
information about what i i put in that
outline
so
what i wanted to cover today my
understanding of the type of information
you're looking for is
a little bit about what it takes to be
able to finance a new renewable energy
project
specific to the new hampshire context
so i'll cover some pretty broad
information and then
dan clapp who works at revision energy
who is a co-founder of revision energy
can go into a little bit more detail
for example i also won't cover um
federal policy the investment tax credit
the itc
on the federal side is very important to
financing some renewable energy projects
but i'll leave that probably to dan or
jeff to talk about
so
first and foremost
broad context i do want to mention that
new hampshire has more conservative
incentive and attributes less value
and has lower goals for renewable energy
than all other new england states so
when i'm talking to renewable energy
developers were often a standout in that
aspect
also when i talk to our business members
who are renewable energy developers
they
really focus on
policy stability and consistency and
predictability
as a need
something that they need and are looking
for to be able to finance new projects
um so this morning for example when we
talk about senate bill 78 the
consistency in the re-bid and grant
programs that's something that they're
looking for
when we're talking about grandfathering
the adder for low moderate income
community solar projects that's
something they're looking for it's that
type of
policy consistency predictability
durability
for example
one of the things that is challenging in
financing renewable energy projects is
that our net metering credit is tied to
the default service rate
which changes every six months or every
month depending on what type of customer
you are
so that makes it difficult when you're
potentially financing
a project that's going to last 20 25 30
years
to be able to model out what your
revenue stream might be or what your
payback on investment might be
not knowing what the default energy
service rate will be
so i'll go over a little bit on
obviously when you're trying to develop
a renewable energy project these are
businesses nobody is developing
renewable energy out of the goodness of
their heart so they are looking for
projects that make economic sense
so that means either a reasonable
payback on investment or something that
will generate net revenue
to understand that we have to understand
what are the revenue streams for
renewable energy projects and what types
of revenue streams are available to what
types of projects
we at clean energy new hampshire
advocate for all types of renewable
energy so i'm going to try to speak
broadly about all renewable energy and
at all scales so obviously it is very
different situation if you're putting a
few solar panels on a residential roof
or if you're building a utility scale
renewable energy project
but i'll try and speak broadly
for all those technologies and all those
types of projects
so as far as revenue streams
there are three broad categories
energy
capacity
and what's called the environmental
attributes which are documented
as renewable energy certificates or
wrecks
for energy there's i would say three
broad categories of potential
of where you may be getting your revenue
for energy
renewable energy projects can
participate in the iso new england
wholesale markets
and they may either get day ahead
pricing or real-time pricing
so um
it may not be as easy as it seems
however to participate in the wholesale
market
it can be costly and require
considerable expertise
and therefore is not likely appropriate
for very small generators
some recent
example of wholesale prices
ice in new england reports the monthly
average
november was two and a half cents that's
pretty um
representative of the last year
recently in the winter the prices have
gone up
these prices uh
4.4
and then in february 7.2 cents that's
really high so in the two to three cents
per kilowatt hour is more representative
of the average of of wholesale prices
another broad category of where you may
get your revenue
for energy as a renewable energy project
is from contracts so here in new
hampshire currently we're seeing
um quite a bit of interest in developing
larger scale renewable energy projects
which in many cases have won bids in the
clean energy procurements of other
states
so that gives those developers a
long-term contracts at a negotiated
price
and that gives them the certainty and
stability to be able to finance those
projects
that may be energy only or it may be
energy and wrecks depending on the
details of the procurement and the
details of the contract
another option for contracts includes
power purchase agreements or corporate
procurements
however
some of the details there still has to
be a mechanism to make those
transactions a reality
so
in a lot of cases it is challenging to
be able to
actually effectuate such transactions i
talk to people all the time that say
i've got some land could i just put some
solar on here and sell it to a business
down the street
that would be great however it is very
challenging to actually figure out the
mechanisms of those transactions
and so that's why in many cases
something like group net metering is
necessary to be able to effectuate those
transactions
so i hear all the time for example that
net metering
the limitation to one megawatt doesn't
prevent anyone from building
a two megawatt solar array if they want
and that is correct
however the
the regulatory mechanism to effectuate
transactions between a generator and a
buyer
is one of the things that groupnet
metering allows
that is
really necessary and currently the
easiest most user-friendly way of
facilitating some of those transactions
for the credit from the generator to go
to the group members
so the other way
to get revenue for energy generated is
net metering
net metering is not
getting money for selling electricity to
the grid
i
want to be clear that you cannot just
act as a generator if you are a net
metering host or a customer generator
and get paid to act as a generator
the primary purpose of net metering is
to allow
to net out behind the meter usage from
your bill
and then as regular net metering you are
also allowed to get credit on your bill
for energy exported in excess
of what you're consuming behind the
meter
those credits can again get used on your
against your bill in a different billing
cycle
under group net metering
the credits generated by the host
account or the generator
can be attributed or shared with member
accounts
which there has to be a full group or
contract
between the host and the members
and all of the electricity generated by
the host
has to be
accounted for by the members so the
member's total energy usage
has to be equal or greater than the host
generation
so that's
revenue options for electricity or
energy generation
capacity payments
for renewable energy generators
participating in the wholesale market
they may bid into iso new england's
forward capacity auction
and receive monthly capacity payments
so
if you are
doing net metering
any kind of distributed generation you
are not eligible
to get capacity payments
um so that's a revenue stream that's not
available to you
there are some exceptions to that
um sunrun for example was able to
aggregate
solar paired with storage and bid that
into the capacity auction i believe two
years ago
and ferc
order2222
aims to increase the access of
distributed energy resources to
wholesale and capacity markets so that's
something that both ferc and the isos
are working on developing
to increase the access of these types of
technologies to both the wholesale and
so finally um i will mention that
there's different compensation for
capacity based on your projected
generation your capacity factor
as well as
iso now has in place a pay for
performance system which means that if
they hit a critical peak
and you have a capacity obligation and
you do not generate
to meet your capacity obligation there
is a significant financial penalty
and so for an intermittent resource
there can be a risk there
that um if you're not generating for
whatever reason it's not just for
intermittent resources really it's for
any resource
if you don't have enough fuel on site or
you had an unplanned outage
there's something wrong with your
interconnection at the moment
you then have a penalty to pay for not
performing according to your capacity
obligation
finally uh the third category of revenue
is the environmental attributes or the
renewable energy certificates
so rex can be sold and be a source of
revenue for renewable energy system
owners i do want to be clear
that the wrecks are for the renewable
energy system owner
i have talked to some folks that
sometimes have a misconception
that the developer or the installer of
these systems is who benefits from rex
and that's not the case so if you have a
residential solar system
the owner of the rex is the owner of the
system not the business that insult
they can be
rex can also be retired by the system
owner if they wish to keep and claim the
wrecks as the environmental attribute so
this can be important for businesses
or governmental bodies that have uh
goals to achieve net neutra uh not net
neutrality
uh net zero carbon emissions for example
they might want to hold on to their
wrecks to be able to claim the
environmental attributes of their
systems
rec value can vary greatly
according depending on supply and demand
for those wrecks so
rex
is um
the demand for rex is based on the
renewable portfolio standard obligation
so all utilities and electricity
suppliers have obligations to meet
according to the renewable portfolio
standard goals and so that dictates the
demand the supply depends on
how much how many projects are operating
how much renewable energy was generated
in some cases
some projects can cross-qualify across
multiple states
so for example
some of the biomass projects were
selling their wrecks into connecticut
for a while
i don't think that's the case anymore
some of the hydro projects are cost can
be cross-qualified in new hampshire and
massachusetts if they meet the strict
requirements
but there are
strict requirements so not all renewable
energy projects in new hampshire
meet the requirements to be rec eligible
for example
for hydro there's requirements on fish
passage for biomass there's very strict
emission
standards
so for all of the these categories in
every state there are specific
requirements to be rec eligible
so just because you are a renewable
energy facility of a specific technology
you may not qualify
to be able to
certify wrecks and market them
so it is pretty complex to figure out
the supply and demand especially when
some of these are sold across state
lines because a change in policy in a
neighboring state for example
may affect our wreck market here in new
hampshire
but in general
our new hampshire wrecks have much lower
so some other
important considerations for renewable
energy generators
we do have some grant and rebate
programs here in new hampshire funded by
the renewable energy fund
we discussed that this morning a little
bit the renewable energy fund is funded
from alternative compliance payments
which means that if
an utility or supplier that has an
obligation
under the renewable portfolio standard
cannot meet that obligation by
purchasing rex or they decide not to
sometimes there are wrecks available but
for whatever reason they decide to just
make a payment
it also acts as a sealing price on the
value of racks
if alternative compliance payments are
are made into the fund
those
monies are then used for grant and
rebate programs that are designed to
increase the development and
availability of wrecks
so the idea is that if
suppliers and utilities are making acp
payments there's a lack of supply for
rex in specific categories
grant and rebates available especially
for those specific categories
will
incent the development of more
generation capacity for those types of
technologies and racks
and will increase the supply for
the funding
in
past years has been very limited as i
mentioned this morning
the residential solar rebate program is
out of money for this fiscal year
that happened about halfway through the
year
and as a result um there was a wait list
and now they're not acc the puc is not
accepting applications at all
so the funding can also be very variable
from year to year because it is based on
acp revenues
another uh thing that's important to
renewable energy
projects is the ability to negotiate
pilots or payment in lieu of taxes
this is new hampshire people talk about
property taxes a lot and i hear about
property taxes a lot from renewable
energy developers
for some it is um
their largest expense for for renewable
energy projects
and so it is something that is really
beneficial to the host community so if
you have a renewable energy project in
your town it can
represent significant new tax revenue
for your community
which can be beneficial but renewable
energy projects do have the ability to
negotiate payment in lieu of taxes which
can be beneficial for both the developer
and the town it gives them both the
flexibility to negotiate an agreement
that both agree to and is beneficial for
both
interconnection policies and costs and
grid modernization is something that is
increasingly important and i think would
be critically important to get ahead of
here in new hampshire
we've seen
this become very difficult in states
that are far ahead of us in the
deployment of distributed energy
resources
and
we've already seen some
challenges in certain areas of the state
so we constantly ask for
moving forward with grid modernization
which has been stalled at the commission
for a really long time
we think they would be extremely
beneficial for
more information to be available to
developers regarding the hosting
capacity of the grid for example so that
they may know
where the grid can host more renewable
energy without
a hugely significant
cost to interconnect
because all costs to interconnect new
projects to the grid
are completely paid for by the developer
or the system owner and sometimes that
is at considerable expense
and it
takes away an expense that would have
been paid for by rate payers
so it is very important to get ahead of
consistent predictable fair
interconnection policies
costs that are manageable
as well as looking at what is needed to
modernize our grid
to benefit customers and meet their
expectations
then i'll talk about
permitting and soft costs
again businesses want predictability
and stability and consistency
so there is increasing
move to potentially be more strict with
the development of renewable energy
we're watching very closely the
development of permitting standards
specific to large solar developments at
the department of environmental services
regarding stormwater one-off
so we want to make sure that renewable
energy development is treated fairly and
not
overly restrictively
a field of solar panels is very
different than a parking lot and we want
to make sure that any environmental
impact or potential environmental impact
is considered carefully
and that we don't over regulate or
so these are all things that can affect
the cost and the feasibility of
developing a renewable energy project
the permitting and soft costs can be can
really add a lot the interconnection can
completely
tank the the economic viability of a
project
so finally i'm going to talk a little
bit about upfront cost versus ongoing
costs
all renewable energy technologies are
not the same and it can be really
different to finance
a solar project versus a different kind
of project so
some projects like solar have a lot have
almost entirely upfront capital costs
so when you're building a solar project
the upfront costs will be very large
however once the project is built there
is very little ongoing costs so there
are property tax
costs and there may be land lease costs
if the owner doesn't own the land
however there's not significant
labor there's minimal maintenance you
might have to just
mow the field twice a year things like
that
wind is similar to solar
there's a more maintenance costs because
you have moving parts
hydro has
very large upfront costs but it also has
significant ongoing costs
that include labor
maintenance taxes
as well as re-licensing and so
a lot of our
small hydro projects here in new
hampshire are at the point where they're
going through ferc relicensing
and that is a very costly
very long and difficult
process
to be able to keep these pro these
projects online and generating local
renewable energy for us
biomass
also has significant upfront costs to
develop the infrastructure
they
have ongoing costs including maintenance
and labor but they also have fuel costs
unlike those the other renewable
technologies
solar wind and hydro don't have fuel
costs whereas biomass does
i did want to touch briefly on
some examples for revenue stream or
different approaches that other states
have taken
for renewable energy
so i've mentioned a little bit clean
energy procurements
other new england states have done
what's called clean energy procurements
where they ask their utilities to
put out requests for proposals that meet
certain criteria
some of them as i mentioned are for
energy alone some are for energy and
renewable energy certificates together
and some of them require other proposals
to be part of the contracts
recently with offshore wind some of them
require a certain amount of
promised or documented
local economic development
so saying we are going to create this
many jobs we're going to
invest in your local port we're going to
use your local port to develop these
projects for example
so there's been very competitive pricing
in some of these renewable energy
procurements recently
maine was the most recent and
they saw
a mix of solar hydro and biomass bidding
into that those contracts
and um i believe the average price was
around 3.9 cents a kilowatt hour
so very competitive with the wholesale
market as i as i had explained earlier
massachusetts is now in its what's
called what they call their smart
program which is a declining block
program with adders
and so they have very aggressive
renewable energy goals they are seeking
certain um
declining blocks so there's higher value
for the first project for the initial
projects and then as they satisfy a
certain amount of bid in capacity
the value goes down however they have
a whole series of adders for different
types of projects so i get asked all the
time why massachusetts has solar on
almost every capital and phil but we
have only i believe one current one
project in new hampshire like that
and it's in part because massachusetts
said
let's really use this type of land that
can't be used for anything else
where folks probably won't complain
about siting a project on it
and they really went and incentivized
putting solar on capped landfills
through these adders and so these are
their
their net metering credit for example is
already way more generous than ours
they're putting an adder on top of that
additional value to really drive
development in certain locations
or for example to serve low moderate
income
customers
or to put it over a parking lot
or
anything like that
so that's a different approach
and then another approach is what's
called a feed-in tariff which
guarantees grid access
it's a long-term contract and it's a set
price
again that's what developers really love
to see to be able to have the confidence
to finance new projects
vermont for example has had a feed in
tariff for renewable energy
and a lot of countries in europe have
used feed and tariffs to
incentivize the development of renewable
energy
a lot of times it it sort of has that
declining block approach where
the tariff is more generous initially
and as you start to make progress
towards meeting the goals or the cost of
the systems go down or whatever you can
have
sort of a declining value over time
so that is about what i
wanted to cover with all of you but i'm
okay thank you for that very uh thorough
explanation of
the realities of
financing for renewable energy projects
i would like to call on representative
sorry about that um thank you archer and
um
i'm serious about two things in
particular and maybe i'll ask for we
can't hear you very well uh
representative partial
well i'll tell you what let me turn my
microphone up here a little bit is that
much better much better
yeah i'm i'm that's you know i have too
many buttons in front of me here
um
you were talking about um
a penalty for non-performance and
supplying uh energy once some small
providers uh
now how is that levied and what happens
to that penalty um
can you speak a little bit more about
that i would love to know more about
that
another thing you were speaking of and i
and i this is again
um
you're talking about um
retaining wrecks uh if you wanted to do
that i understand that's a problem in
doing that the way the current the way
it's being currently uh
wraps are being taken by the power
industry i was wondering if you speak to
that
and lastly i don't really want to open
this can of worms but of all the energy
i did notice that we did not bring up
the idea of nuclear energy um i
understand there have been problems over
the years with that i understand we're
looking at different technology
uh so not not to get deep into it but
could just you know
ten words or less why no nuclear
and uh thank you
yeah i'll actually start with the last
question um so we don't consider nuclear
energy to be renewable um because it
does require a fuel that is mined that
is a limited resource
so
it certainly is clean it doesn't emit
any carbon dioxide it's not you know
putting out emissions into the air
however
when we're focusing on renewable
resources we don't consider nuclear to
be renewable because you have to mine
uranium or
you know fuel and so that's why we don't
lump it into the category of renewable
regarding um
the penalty for non-performance
that is part of iso new england's
capacity
auction and market
and so if you have a capacity obligation
so every year in february iso new
england has a forward capacity auction
looking three years into the future
if you are a wholesale market
participant and you decide to bid into
the forward capacity market
three years into the future
you receive monthly capacity payments
from icer new england
which are paid for by customers through
your default energy service rate
um
there was a concern
when originally when there was a
capacity market there was no penalty
like this and so there was a concern
that you're being paid
to be available
but if you were not in fact available
and you didn't in fact generate when you
were needed
there was no penalty and so you're
getting a payment for a service but if
you did not
render the service there was no
consequence
and so i so developed this pay for
performance system
where if you if they hit a critic
you know when they
they determine there's a critical peak
event
and you do not in fact generate the
electricity you had bid into the
capacity market at that
three years ago
then you would have a penalty and so um
you i'm not sure exactly how the payment
is made um you either make the payment
or
they will i'm guessing not pay you your
next capacity payment until um the
penalty is is paid
uh
and then the second question i'm
failing to remember
uh that's concerned about uh retaining
wrecks oh yes um the way you phrase that
maybe
think that right now well as we i think
we're all aware the uh our utility
companies would come and take the
unclaimed unregistered wrecks yes it's
kind of a sensitive point to some people
i just want to speak to that yes so
there is wreck sweeping in new hampshire
and those are for unregistered racks and
so a lot of the systems that
their racks are being swept it is
sometimes because they're older systems
and they don't have
the right inverter to be able to
register and confirm that they're
generating racks or something like that
so
if
somebody installs solar on your roof and
you're like great i have a solar system
and you don't do anything
to register to be eligible
to either sell or retire your wrecks
then those wrecks get
credited for free at no cost to the
utilities or suppliers
according to the rec sweeping
calculation
however if you go through the trouble of
filing the paperwork and becoming
eligible
to market your racks
you can sell them
or you cannot sell them and keep them
and that's what's called retiring your
wrecks and so if you want to be able to
claim the attribute the environmental
attributes of your system
like some especially this is
mostly done by large corporations that
have made you know if you want to be
able to put on your product made with
100 renewable energy and you have solar
on your factory
you can't at the same time be selling
your racks and be able to make that
claim
otherwise the whoever bought your wrecks
yes go on concerning uh the
retaining wrecks is that a difficult
um i understand there have been barriers
in the past to actually registering your
wrecks in order to sell them i
understand it's easier now
but if you want to retain is that a
fairly simple process
so
so as i mentioned a lot of the systems
that their wrecks are being swept it is
older systems so they just like
everything else there's a lot of
requirements to be able to
authenticate document and confirm that
your system is producing
this much energy and therefore
a rack was generated that can be
marketed
and there are some systems that don't
meet
some of those technological requirements
especially some of the older ones you
have to have
and i don't know the details and dan
clap later might be able to to answer
those details but i know that some of
the older solar systems that were
installed a while ago they just don't
have the right inverter for example to
meet the standard to say oh
now we can document that your
your system generated this much energy
and we can confirm it and document it
and verify it
so there are some technical barriers and
so some system owners might not want to
invest in an upgrade on their system to
be able to meet those requirements
and then there is just the typical
there's a lot of bureaucracy around it
right so it's a lot of paperwork it's a
lot of documenting things everything has
a cost your time has a cost and so some
system owners don't just want to go
through the the whole rigmarole of going
through the
trouble of registering
and then there's also a lot of unknown a
lot of system owners think that they are
effectively retiring their racks by
inaction
and don't know that rec sweeping exists
it's a pretty obscure policy we do a lot
to try and educate people about it but
some system owners just don't know that
if they do nothing their wrecks then get
credited for free to a utility or a
supplier
thank you so much for that answer thank
you chair
rigmarole is that a technical term
love it
uh representative mcgee is recognized
for the question
thank you mr chair and thank you ms
minnow for this enlightening testimony
it's always good to hear it again and
again and again so we can maybe get it
down sometime my question um
let's see i wrote it down here
um
i'm concerned with how our policies
might be affecting
um the market the health of the market
the energy market the renewable energy
market in new hampshire and so from your
testimony it sounds like hydro
might be having increased difficulty
staying in operation because of the
regulatory and other hurdles that they
have to
abide in order to turn a profit as as a
business
and then
i know that biomass plants based on
recent policy also sort of went
mothballed and then they just got
acquired i think a whole bunch of them
were bought up by a company in maine
which means we don't have control of
those assets anymore
and then
the last thing i wrote down here was
that
you mentioned that our solar policies
are still
not stable
enough to be really desirable for
companies that are looking to figure out
what welcoming markets they want to
participate in so it seems like we're
we're there's a compound of factors here
that are going to affect the value of
wrecks in new hampshire
and i wondered if you could say
something about
how the wreck market contributes to
a healthy system
or system that works for the people that
are trying to operate in that space
since you're explaining how
the financial part of it works
yeah so as i mentioned the rac system
rex can be one of the
one of the
revenue streams for projects
and so
it's also a policy statement from the
state so wrecks are part of the
renewable portfolio standard
currently new hampshire's goals for the
renewable portfolio standard is 25
renewable energy by 2025. when you look
at the other new england states they're
saying we're going to 80
we're going to 100
and so that is
a you know a policy of the state saying
we are going to be
really going after
welcoming these businesses to come
develop renewable energy in our state
and we are going to
provide a
policy framework which is the renewable
portfolio standard to make sure that
that happens
there's also
those alternative compliance payments
acting as ceiling values for racks
so
for example a solar rack an s rack in
massachusetts has was worth
a wreck
here in new hampshire in recent years
we've seen values for our class two
solar racks to be as low as two dollars
or five dollars
so we're talking about two orders of
magnitude less and so obviously
the businesses are going to be going to
massachusetts because developing a solar
array there
is going to be much more
inviting
then to do that here and that creates
jobs that creates local investment as i
mentioned that's property tax payments
it's it's a lot of investment and yes
the other technologies i mentioned in
part because sometimes i get asked
a hydro project is existing
why in the world does it need support
right it's already there it's already
built
well there are ongoing costs there are
significant regulatory costs the the
re-licensing going through re-licensing
is
can be millions of dollars right
and then when you get through in order
to get through re-licensing you have all
sorts of new environmental standards to
meet and so it may require significant
infrastructure investment building a new
fish ladder building a new downstream
fish passage ladder you may have
restrictions on your operations maybe
you used to be able to peak and now you
can only run run of river that reduces
your generation capacity
you may
have to shut down at night when it rains
a certain amount to let the eels go by
that reduces your generation capacity
there's all sorts of requirements like
that that can be put on a project
to
enable to negotiate to get through
re-licensing and so that all impacts the
economics of a project it can also
increase your labor cost
depending on how you're told you have to
operate to be able to continue to
generate similarly with biomass you know
fuel costs which are
directly reinvested in the local economy
but that's something that other projects
don't have they have more ongoing costs
and when we talk about all these
technologies to us it is critically
important to have fuel diversity
whenever you're looking at planning an
electric grid you don't want to put all
your eggs in one basket
whether that's
one type of renewable energy
or one type of fossil fuel energy or
nuclear or whatever it is fuel diversity
is critically important to resilience
and protecting against the volatility
of the fuel in one technology for
example
yeah thank you can i just have a quick
follow-up
well you had to uh we have other people
who would like to ask questions
oh okay all right thanks representative
thank you mr chairman i've got two
unrelated questions you mentioned other
states with goals of 80 to 100 percent
renewables what do you think the impact
will be on the central island new
england market but they reach goals like
that
i mean i think we're all in a regional
grid right so if those states especially
the states that have the most
significant load like massachusetts
reach their goal of of being
um
net zero or reaching 100 renewable
energy
uh certainly it will significantly uh
increase the amount of renewable energy
in the iso new england grid
overall
uh well i guess my question was really
related to if they don't have no control
over that renewable energy and they're
relying on
what is they call generation and it's
becoming a vanish in a small part of
the total supply what happens to the
excellent market but that's maybe too
complicated the question um do you mean
it's outside of the wholesale market
right
yes um that is a challenge i mean we
hear our friends at nepka regularly say
that they really would like
um
the renewable you know the renewable
energy generation to be within the
wholesale markets and some of these
state procurements that are outside of
the wholesale market is a challenge to
that
so there is has been many
calls on the isis the rtos
to take into account more the states
that make them up uh their renewable
energy goals
and and their policies as they do system
planning and so i think that's a
regional dialogue that's going on um you
know the nesco states put out a
statement recently some states have put
out very strong statements like
connecticut
really urging iso new england to start
to take their own state's policies into
account
as they do their planning and their work
and to figure out a way to be able to
meet those states policies
within
within the the system and the wholesale
market
you also mentioned feed in garrison how
they're used in europe that includes
germany at brazil yes what's been the
impact on consumer electric prices in
germany from feeding tariffs
uh i don't have exact data on current uh
and historical
prices in germany i'm sorry
i do but i'm not supposed to testify
okay
okay thank you representative regina has
recognized her question thank you mr
chairman and thank you miss minnow for
taking my question you mentioned that in
massachusetts
it provides incentives for installing
solar panels on landfills
are there extra costs or disincentive
when installing solar panels on capped
landfills
yes so the adders are meant to
compensate for extra costs so putting a
solar system on a landfill landfills
generally have a cap landfills have a
membrane that's the same uh issue if
you're putting a solar system on a
former superfund site or landfill you're
not able to
penetrate the surface so typically when
you do a ground mounted solar array you
can drive piles
so that the posts are into the ground
you're not able to do that on a landfill
because you would pierce the membrane
and so there are added costs you usually
have to do um
ballasted systems so there's very large
concrete blocks for example or other
like a pipe filled with concrete that
can hold the array onto the surface
without digging into the ground or the
the surface
similarly folks ask me all the time why
there's not more solar over parking lots
it is more expensive to build a solar
car port
than it is to build a regular ground
mounted solar array and so in in order
to encourage the development of these
systems that are more costly but there
are benefits of putting a solar ray over
a parking lot or on a capped landfill
so
adders generally are needed to
compensate for the extra cost of those
systems
uh thank you mr chairman
ms minnow um
i'm concerned that we are
in a cycle actually it's probably been
going on for
eternity but
um
where every uh change of
uh administration
where we where the majority changes from
one party to the other
we go through a cycle of
new legislation which reverses
what the previous legislation
legislator has done
and
i mean you you talked about it a little
bit
these long-term projects
need long-term
stability
are we going to have a difficult time
no matter what we do
to
to reverse that kind of mindset i mean
are are people going to be looking or
companies going to be looking at new
hampshire is not a good place to invest
because of the cycling that
is going on
and i do have a follow-up on that as
well
so i can say this isn't unique to new
hampshire right this happens everywhere
in every state and at the federal level
to have changes in administrations and
changes in policies
yes when you're looking to finance a a
project based on a certain policy you
want to make sure that that policy is as
stable and predictable as possible
and so that's why
when we work on certain policies as i
mentioned we tried to put in
grandfathering clause so that if you
build a project based on a policy that's
in effect at the time
it is extremely beneficial to say
that if you go in service today and that
policy exists today
you have that tariff guaranteed to you
for 20 years for example and that is
something that we always try to make
sure and explain why that's so important
to have in a policy because
if we change our minds next year because
there's a different administration we
don't want that project that made a
significant investment to then be
have the rug pulled out from under them
so there are ways to craft policies to
make sure that there's predictability
and stability at least for the projects
that get built
while the policy is in effect of course
if you change the policy
future future projects won't be able to
use that policy going forward but at
least that the projects that made an
investment based on that policy should
have some amount of guarantee of
stability
um
yeah so i'd say that's that's what's
most important to us there's always
going to be some changes in the future
we clean energy i can say that when i
try to you know
really advocate for a policy i try to
make sure it has bipartisan support
it's really challenging to build those
coalitions but that's a way to ensure
that if it's got some support from both
follow-up chairman
go ahead
okay
thank you and my follow-up is actually
concerns
uh a little bit about what you talked
about with uh
uh
solar arrays going above
parking lots and on landfills that that
you you you basically killing two birds
with one stone so to speak and one of
the things other things are t-rex
how we're really killing multiple birds
with the same stone and and
there has been discussion about
eliminating t-rex
and
that
because it's thermal energy
we should be taxing
uh um
for instance oil or gas and not
electricity in some way and i'm just
wondering
um i mean i can sort of understand that
but what is the feasibility of
doing that
and
not only that but
how how are we going to deal with all
these
other birds that we've killed with this
t-rex stone whether it's uh you know
keeping our forests healthy and
um
the many things that we're getting out
of
these t-rexes
we don't like to talk about dead birds
and renewable energy we always
get too many questions about wind
turbines and birds dying so we won't
talk about killing too many birds but um
i understand what you're saying
certainly um i mean we have advocated
for the inclusion of thermal in in our
energy
obviously if we're looking at
economic development benefits which is
primarily what we focus on
there is tremendous benefit to the state
to
to buy locally produced thermal fuel
and use those technologies
with
with strict emission
limits which are in place to be able to
qualify for those thermal wrecks right
there's an environmental benefit there
as well
there's very little benefit to buying
heating oil for the economy of new
hampshire
you know you're paying the guy that or
the woman that's delivering it to you
but that's about it other than that the
the money goes out of state so um
the to us why the renewable portfolio
standard was put in place was for fuel
diversity and that applies not just to
electricity it also applies to buildings
economic benefits to the state
and environmental benefits
if we're serious about reducing
emissions
then we should be tackling the heating
sector and the building sector as well
as the electricity sector
you know some states have
renewable
electricity standards and we are very
proud here in new hampshire that we have
a renewable energy standard because it
is not just applying to electricity
um maine has recently done the same and
added thermal energy to their to their
renewable portfolio standard
so i mean
where the funding comes from
yeah i think it would be a lot more
challenging to tax
non-regulated fuels which is what a lot
okay thank you next step is
thank you mr chairman and thank you uh
miss minnow for coming and giving us
this great presentation
um i've got two questions i think
they're pretty simple for you to answer
can you explain a little bit to everyone
um
what what is the forward capacity market
so we all get the same
understanding and secondly can you tell
me something about how does
supply demand work with regard to the
acp payments
how are they connected
the alternative compliance payments yeah
so the forward capacity
market is as i mentioned it's an auction
an annual auction that the grid operator
is new england holds
every year in february looking three
years into the future
and so they are looking to secure enough
capacity to meet demand
probably and then some so they also look
to have a little bit of a cushion
and that's the way that they make sure
that
three years into the future we are going
to have enough generators online to be
able to meet demand no matter what
and so generators will
put a bid into the the capacity auction
and say i offer up the availability of
my capacity in three years
for this much money and so
there's right there iso is going to
start say okay i'm going to take the
the cheapest bids first and then they go
up in value until they get to the amount
of capacity they're looking to procure
to meet all of the projected demand in
three years
once you have a capacity obligation
you when that month comes up where your
capacity obligation is
you get your payment
and so that payment
says
we we are paying you for existing and
being available to generate
and as i mentioned now there's this pay
for per for permit system
you may not be generating
you know you're not being paid to
actually generate electricity that's the
separate revenue stream of electricity
and energy production that i mentioned
the capacity payment is paying you for
being available to generate for existing
and you could be on standby or you could
be generating it depends you're really
being paid for your availability
and that is how the system operator
plans ahead and makes sure that there
will be enough generation available
when it's needed
so some plants for example that are
peaker plants that don't generate very
often
they are still economically viable
because of these capacity payments
that are really paying them to be
available when needed only during those
peak events
and then
acps and supply and demand of racks so
that's demand of racks is dictated by
the obligations
so we have four classes in the renewable
portfolio standard class 1 which is
a big bucket of new renewables the
subclass of class 1 thermal
class 2 which is solar class 3 which is
biomass electric and class 4 which was
existing small hydro
so there are specific
obligations that are equal to a
percentage
of the entire load of new hampshire
to meet those specific technologies and
so
every utility so the big utilities
as well as
competitive suppliers have these
obligations proportional to the load
that they serve
and so they have a choice they can go
out to generators and say hey do you
have any wrecks i can buy i'm looking
for class 2 racks i'm looking for class
3 rex
there is also an acp value so for
example for
class 1 rex it's 57
a megawatt hour
a megawatt hour is equivalent to one
rack
so
i always have the choice as say i'm a
utility i say you got any class 1 racks
i can buy i need to buy
10 recs for example
somebody will say oh sure i'll sell them
to you for 60 dollars and i'll say no
thanks
i'll go make an alternative compliance
payment so that's how it acts as a
ceiling price because you always have
the option of making the alternative
compliance payments but if i say you got
any class one recs i can buy and they
say oh yeah sure here they are for uh
i'll i'll sell them to you for fifty
dollars each
or i'll sell them to you for
but maybe there's an over supply and so
then maybe i get into a bidding war with
some other generators and the utility
ends up being able to buy them for just
25 a wreck
so that's how the supply also affects
the value
the acp value is the ceiling price so
anyone with an obligation should never
have to pay more than that
but typically there is more supply than
there is demand and so the value of the
racks is lower than the ceiling price
and the more supply there is on the
system
the more the sort of the better deal the
obligations can get and so when we talk
about if we increase our renewable
portfolio standard goals
what will the cost be
um
a lot of times the values that you may
get are the worst case scenario which is
assuming that every rack is selling at
the acp value at the ceiling price
in reality that's unlikely typically the
wrecks are sold
okay
next up is representative callie pitts
thank you
i had two questions one thing
and and the things i really don't
understand as i listen to you talk about
the wrecks and i've been here 25 years
and a adding payments adders and doing
things to incentivize people
i understand that there's a climate
problem but
you get a grant and i'm talking about an
individual now get a grant to build a
home to build a system
you net meter
so you don't pay
much of an electricity you pay for trans
transmission and distribution and what
you don't use
and then you get wrecks
that
why is there a problem
getting people to do things
when it seems to me like
they're really making out
and the other question
that
comes along is
as a business a regular businesses
customer base
shrinks
somebody's got to pick up the slack for
that
and
it's not going to be the the customer
who's not using that business it's going
to be the customer who is utilizing the
business so could you try to clarify
those two because they are really
they have baffled me over the years and
i i just
sure i don't understand it
so um say we're talking about dan clap
can maybe talk about this in more
realistic detail but i'm going to use
some rough numbers
say you're want to put a solar array on
a on a typical single family house
um here in new hampshire you're like all
right um it's going to be like a 7
kilowatt array i think is pretty typical
that might cost you
25 000
so you go to the puc you say hey here
there's a rebate program funded from the
renewable energy fund can i get a rebate
there if it's available like right now
they would say nope sorry we're all out
of money for this year if it's available
they're gonna say sure you get one
thousand dollars so that lowers
your cost from twenty five thousand to
twenty four
um
then you apply for net metering um
hopefully there's not a significant cost
to interconnect your system right
eversource could say
you're gonna have to replace the
transformer on the pole in your
neighborhood to be able to interconnect
your system that could make the system
prohibitively expensive so hopefully
there's no significant cost so you get
to interconnect you get net metering
you used to pay um
all-in cost of say 18 to 20 cents a
kilowatt hour when we're talking about
everything
in your bill
um the net metering credit for a small
array is closer to
12 to 13 cents a kilowatt hour i think
if you're cons so it's electricity 25
of distribution transmission
so you're still always paying your
customer charge your non-bypassable
charges
and 75 of the distribution system
so you're still not
you know
paying nothing you're paying the the
commission determined that that's you're
paying your fair share of the grid
so you're not you know getting off
scot-free so with all of that you're
still looking at a significant payback
period for your system
that with the one thousand dollar rebate
you're paying twenty four thousand
dollars
so even though your bill will be reduced
with the net metering being able to net
out your behind the meter usage
if you
exported more in august you're really
just using that credit when your array
produces less in winter months for
example
so you're still likely not zeroing out
your electric bill
and
you still have significant cost to pay
back so it's still a pretty big barrier
for folks there's financing available
there are also federal
tax incentives if you have the tax
burden to be able to realize those
incentives
and
may i follow up mr chair yes
i don't know where you are um would
and the payback on that average system
just average and the average usage what
they figure out
would be
what about 10 years
um i think
i think so yeah about
i think eight to ten years
and the system
lasts 20 years
25 yeah
thank you okay next up is representative
sausage
sorry mr chairman i forgot to take down
oh okay
um
well i guess we're all done with
questions here then so i guess uh we can
thank ms minnow for an excellent
presentation
thank you and i'll stick around if
anybody if any other questions specific
to me pop up after um dan and jeff speak
okay that sounds good
dan clapp i believe from
thanks representative revision energy
revision energy okay yeah where is yours
thank you um
i'm joining late here just got off
another meeting so i
don't want to i'm sure madeline did a
wonderful job covering
the state of um the solar market and
financing in new hampshire so
maybe i'll just quickly introduce myself
the company the markets we serve
and then open it up for for questions um
yeah revision energy we're an
employee-owned b corp we have locations
in brentwood new hampshire
in enfield new hampshire so the upper
valley and the seacoast
we've been operating in new hampshire
since 2008
we also have locations in maine and
massachusetts as well
um but we serve both the residential
market and the commercial market and
when i say the commercial market i'm
gonna break it down into two different
buckets one is on-site
commercial
um so that's that's a small business
rooftop ground mount or quote-unquote
behind the meter when you build an array
that's service servicing load behind the
meter and then also off-site solar so
when you start to build some larger
multi-megawatt systems um off-site
and that gets into group net metering et
cetera and we we build most of those in
maine in in massachusetts not not new
hampshire
at this point just because maybe what
madeline touched upon some of the
economics but what it what it comes down
to is
you have your build costs or what they
refer to as epc
engineering procurement construction
costs
and that's going to be dictated by where
the where the array is the type of the
array whether it's roof mount ground
mount the technology you're going to
deploy the solar panels
and it also includes some of the soft
costs that we have permitting
for example which in new hampshire you
know it's done at the local level and so
every every town handles a little
differently so you know overall our soft
costs are relatively high in new
hampshire just because there's no
consistency
um the lack of consistency i should say
in some of the permitting so that comes
down to your your actual build cost what
madeline was talking about in her
example of that seven kilowatt array um
of 25 000. now as a pr as a company
we're constantly trying to drive those
prices down and be as efficient as
possible um you know and competitive in
the market which is which is great
so based on those bill costs you have
you know you got to figure out what your
generation is and the generation is
based on your azimuth your pitch
your shading um and the system size and
what that's going to that's going to
dictate what it produces on an annual
basis monthly and annual
and in kilowatt hours and tied to those
kilowatt hours is a generation and the
value of the kilowatt hour and that is
you know your revenue stream so you're
gonna
madeline touched on rex rex's one
revenue stream and the other one is the
value of the kilowatt hour and
i passed around i think ahead of this
meeting just a overall policy
update
and when it when you look at new
hampshire and that value of the kilowatt
hour in in our neighboring states and as
you know we're all part of iso new
england you know we're on average about
40 percent
less or fewer in our value of the
kilowatt hour that we place on our
generation than our neighboring states
and that has put us at a competitive
disadvantage in in
and has driven our driven our payback
times up um and
this number of solar adopters down so we
have a lack of distributed generation in
the state because our economics is not
as strong as our neighboring states
so those are two key points
and then
when you also look at your financials
you also want to look at your expenses
and solar has
annual o m expenses operation and
maintenance expenses they're they're
pretty low because that system is we
expect it to be operational 25 plus
years the warranties are 25 years
warranties are 12 years on the inverters
25 years in the panels
but we also have
taxes that we need to pay and in new
hampshire does not have a consistent
approach
to how they tax these systems so when we
start talking about larger commercial
especially off-site systems that that's
a key component on the expense side of
the equation
so just balancing revenue and expenses
and as far as you know financing it
really depends on the market we're
serving right there's plenty of options
of finance on the residential side of
the business plenty of banks that that
offer a really competitive product
similar to
the on-site commercial a lot of these
businesses
will have a
working lending relationship
with a bank that's willing to lend on
this asset because it is a revenue
generating asset um for the business
and then also this on the commercial
off-site market segment there's plenty
of standards institutional investors
that are willing to invest in these
types of projects again
i see that happening more in maine in
massachusetts because of much stronger
um incentives and
in a stronger value of the kilowatt hour
that we're placing
um on it rather
than in new hampshire
so we're seeing much higher solar
adoption in those states than we are
here in in the granite state
um
i'm gonna just
stop there and and open it up to the
floor with any questions
that you have um i i did if you have any
questions specific to
the market update that i put together
i'm happy to
answer some of those as well
okay dan thank you representative sumps
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
i um to ask you about um
you mentioned a couple times of the
differences between the various states
that you serve massachusetts maine new
hampshire
and in that context you are you were
talking about your soft costs
and your local requirements and
communities um
uh in other other uh countries that are
doing this that they basically
differentiate between the cost of the
the actual equipment the seller
collectors versus their soft costs
and um
do you have can you tell me a little bit
about
the pricing and and the cost of those
solar collectors historically what the
pricing has done in the last let's say
10 years and also have there been any
any improvements in this in the soft
costs to try to reduce those as well
thank you representative um sure i don't
i
did not come to this meeting with
my
you know
cost stack per se sorry i'm not going to
get into the details but in general the
cost of the technology the cost of the
equipment the hard costs the solar
panels the inverters
those have come down over the past 10
years because the inverter the modules
and panels considerably have come down
when i first got into the business
we were installing seven eight nine
dollars a watt and now we're down to two
to three three dollars and fifty cents a
watt um installed so we've seen
tremendous decrease um
in the in the in the equipment the hard
costs
what we've seen an uptick in is as i
mentioned is the soft cost is permitting
now we
while we have tried to roll out some
streamlined efficiencies and you know
every few years new codes get adopted
and the industry adopts
and
you know you need to
you need to learn and educate and teach
local code enforcement and vice versa
it goes back and forth those way both
ways
um and that just just that just slowly
adds costs over time
in addition
labor costs
have gone up as well um
as you probably all know
the trades are are tight it's a tight
job market in the trades and um
you know those in in for good reasons
100 of all all the installers need to be
licensed electricians
and re-run a in-house program
apprenticeship program
for those licensed electricians but
um
they in the the great thing is they
offer really good well-paying jobs
but those costs have continued to
increase as well so while we've seen a
reduction in
the hard costs and materials we've we've
seen an increase in both labor and soft
costs of permitting and i'll also
mention interconnection as well
not so much um
you know i believe especially on the
small scale generator side
interconnections relatively streamlined
with utilities but once you get into the
larger projects there's a lot of
unknowns there's a lot of hard costs
you've got to pay with the utilities
such as you know system impact study
ranges anywhere from twenty to thirty
thousand dollars before you can even
move forward with the system
madeline mentioned an example of a
transformer
you know some of those costs do arise
that come up while you're building these
systems on the smaller scale and more
likely on the larger scale so those
costs continue to creep in as well
uh follow mr term
go ahead
uh
mr clap could you uh give me a little
idea of what what are your differences
between
how you approach a residential
installation
yeah um representative are you speaking
can you provide a little bit more
context of what you're looking for well
yes i'm i'm i'm thinking that uh when
the projects go from small to big
i assume there are things that happen
that
on the municipal level for example
requirements that you might have to meet
or or the scale is so much different
compared to like a residential rooftop
installation so um
and is that something
that maybe the state or we as a body
should look into some type of
standardization of these of these
projects so that
that businesses can have confidence that
this is the standard that everyone can
use that might improve and reduce the
cost
it is true the bigger the project
probably slightly more complex but it is
it does come down to scale right uh
you know
i the resident on the residential side
it's relatively straightforward from a
pure engineering interconnection
perspective
the bigger the project more complex it
becomes
mainly from you know design
in potentially interconnection costs
but as far as you know i i maybe
madeline can can jump in here just from
a perspective of of just streamlining
some of the permitting and stuff but you
know we we try to
have some guidelines that we that we
roll out um that we face but it's hard
for me to
it's hard for me to say there's any um
consistency between
between those those three those two i
mean we we take a different approach
where i mean residential is pretty
straightforward homeowner needs to make
a decision when you start getting into
larger
systems
um a little bit more complex with the
business and the tax incentives
the financial arrangements so from the
municipalities for example you start to
enter third party financing agreements
or power purchase agreements to get
these systems um capitalized and
financed and completed
so from a
capital stack perspective a lot
different but from more of a technology
interconnection
you know it's more just your scale there
is some more complexity
and you know larger systems are gonna
trigger
um utility upgrades that smaller systems
would not
and so you need to you know those larger
systems need to be big enough scale
to be able to absorb some of those
additional costs
you know new hampshire
utilities have
in general
you know it's it's been a little bit
tougher in general to interconnect
larger arrays in new hampshire
the
rule of thumb is when you get you know
over half a megawatt of 500 k 500
kilowatts you know utilities that
triggers reclosures which which add a
significant amount of cost um to the
system and
as everybody probably everybody on here
knows that you know
as as the generator you're responsible
for those costs to upgrade and that
becomes that that that's a benefit to
the ratepayer um because we're we're
paying for these um for the distribution
lines to be upgraded
um
you know at no cost to the ratepayer
which is which is a benefit but
i don't know if that answered your
question that i kind of
stared all over the place there but uh
yeah i can add a little bit so as far as
you dan started to get into municipal
projects and third-party ownership or
financing or ppas or leases so we work a
lot with energy committees that want to
look at procuring a solar array for
example a renewable energy project for
their town and
because
one of the big things that can help
finance a
renewable energy project is the federal
investment tax credit
obviously that's not available to
municipality because they're not paying
federal taxes
so that is when we try to advise them
and we've developed some resources to
try and have them put out requests for
proposals that allows them to compare
both
what would it look like to own the
system and what would it look like to do
what's called a power purchase agreement
but have an investor on the system that
can realize that tax credit which
indirectly allows the municipality to
realize the financial benefits of the
tax credit
and then usually there's a buy out
option for the municipality
and so that's something that we i didn't
talk too too much about but
that federal investment tax credit
can be beneficial for business if
they're
investing in their own system but in
order for a municipality or non-profit
to be able to realize that benefit it
you do have to sort of go around it to
have an investor
be able to
invest in that project or back that
project and then effectively sell the
electricity to the municipality
so that the investor can realize the tax
credit and and transfer the value to the
municipality and then oftentimes there's
an option for municipality to buy out
the project on year seven of the project
okay representative pimentel you have a
question
uh
thank you mr chairman
um
one of the things you mentioned uh
mr clapp was the um
that one of the problems with selling
solar panels in new hampshire
was that our that we have a lower cost
of energy compared to our neighboring
states
um
which is kind of surprising to me but
i'm wondering if you have any kind of
insight on on
[Music]
why that is and
you know obviously we want lower prices
yeah thank you representative
yeah so i my specific uh
statement was not to the lower cost of
energy
compared to the other states it was the
lower value of the that we place in the
kilowatt hour
on the generation of the solar array
so
and that that's that's basically due to
our net metering policy
so when you look at vermont maine and
massachusetts
on average what they're valuing the
kilowatt hour to be is about 40 percent
higher than what the what new hampshire
values that kilowatt hour to be
from the generation of these of these
this from the distributed generate
generators here the asset the solar
assets
and so
with that lower value um and i and i
forgot to touch touch upon
you know we've had the investment tax
credit the itc stepped down from 30 to
26 now the 26 will be held for the next
few years before it drops to 22
and 10
that in addition to
you know
us reducing the rebate levels
has made the but has really tightened up
the financials in new hampshire to the
point where
it's it's driving
down roi and up payback um years
we're adopting less and less we're
having fewer businesses
um
transition to you know renewable than we
did in the past and it's just a
combination of factors there so that's
follow-up security
okay follow-up
are we are we putting our price
arbitrarily low or vice versa are they
putting theirs arbitrarily high i mean
uh what how do how did those prices get
determined
thank you
yeah um
i might ask madeline to take this one
but
um you know
the puc docket that came out in two was
2015 madeline i think it wrapped in
2017.
i mean there there's multiple studies
through the new hampshire puc on the
value of solar or value distributed
generation
those studies have been done
independently
and they've been done in other states
and they have found conclusively that
the value of solar is a lot higher than
what we have placing it in new hampshire
so we have yet to do those studies
through our puc in the state
other states have done so
um and the value is higher they have
driven they have made sure they've taken
the conscious choice to
develop more distributed generation
solar in particular um and that is only
benefiting the ratepayers in the long
term
and madeline you might probably give a
much more detailed answer than that yeah
how the values have been determined in
different states are either through
legislation or regulatory processes so
some states will set them in legislation
but most states are done through
regulatory processes at the public
utility commissions or whatever the
equivalent of the public utility
commission is in that state
um are we too low or are they too high
um you know my candid approach would be
that we're too low and they might be a
little overly generous however those
states have made a policy decisions that
that is an investment they want to make
and so if you want to get a lot of
development real fast then sure be
generous and attract a lot of investment
and a lot of new jobs and a lot of
development to your state
that's a great way to get a lot of
development in your state and some of
those states that have made really
aggressive goals for renewable energy or
emission reductions
they're deciding that they really want
to spur development and investment and
so they're doing that by having generous
incentives
i definitely think that our compensation
is undervaluing
distributed generation
representative plett is recognized for a
question
i heard the speaker a couple of times
talk about a benefit to the rape players
one of them
was when he said uh over 500 kilowatts
you need reclosers and those reclosers
are because of the project otherwise
they wouldn't be needed how about how is
putting those rate poses in to take care
[Music]
thank you representative
um yeah it's a it's a good point so
in general i was talking about just
overall utility upgrades but a lot of
time those re-closures they can actually
be smart re-closures and it gives the
utility better control
um
over their voltage in their in their
where the where that power is going so
there is a benefit
on the utility side are they taking
advantage of that that's that's another
question
um
but
the utility and this is where
private developers can work closely with
utilities
and and help in in being smart about
upgrading the distribution grid so we're
actually working towards a smart grid of
the future
and this is this is one opportunity that
you we can we can take advantage of for
sure
there are definitely some upgrades that
you know can be significant so for
example a utility may have said
um over the next 10 years we need to
make a significant upgrade to this
substation and because a large utility
scale project interconnects to that
circuit
involving that substation they may make
a significant investment
to make that substation upgrade early
then the developers make is incurring
that cost for example and that makes it
so that the cost that the utility was
going to
put on their rate payers in the next
five to ten years then is not going to
okay thank you representative samson
yes i believe um mr haydock sent us an
email and said that he unfortunately had
to leave
he did okay
all right thank you uh representative
sam said you're recognized for a
question
oh thank you mr chairman um i just want
to kind of uh follow up my understanding
of how these um
the net value of distributed energy uh
kilowatts are valued uh have to do a lot
with not just the
actual availability of the energy
but mainly about the health impacts
environmental impacts and also economic
impacts
in a particular state and those states
have to make that judgment on their own
about
how much do they think that benefits
their state and i think that's how these
numbers get get put together to to come
up with a net value of the energy
uh is that is that your understanding
it
it is
and i might defer again to madeleine
just in terms of the recent report that
was
um
just completed
right but you're right there's there's
the actual
value of that kilowatt hour generated on
the grid
and
you know reduction in capacity pricing
a bunch of other factors and then
there's the external
value of of societal benefits um and you
can look at them into two different
windows but
yeah so
other states have clear
state policies
that allow their
regulatory commissions for example
to count the
monetary value assigned to an
environmental benefit
because it goes towards achieving a
state policy
here in new hampshire we have no
greenhouse gas reduction goal in statute
and so we are very careful and our
public utilities commission is very
careful
to not assign a value
that there is no state law stating it
has a value
so when we are at the commission and we
are looking at benefit cost analyses for
example
we are only looking at hard
electricity values
so
we um i think dan was referring to the
synapse report that we and other
organizations commissioned
and that looked it broke apart the cost
right so if you're looking just at the
energy value
avoided you know the effect on the
wholesale market in the avoided capacity
they found that
exported distributed solar had a value
of over
13 a kilowatt hour
so that's more than our our projects are
getting
if you do want to consider
public health value environmental value
you start to get very quickly into the
20 cents a kilowatt hour for example
but it is according to each state's
policy
to decide if it is the policy of the
state that those benefits have a value
that should be compensated for or not
and so
we get into these arguments all the time
at the commission and we are told very
clearly that since new hampshire has no
law
that says it would benefit
the residents of new hampshire to reduce
our greenhouse gas emissions we don't
consider environmental value
when we discuss our net metering tariffs
for example
okay um
with that i see no more questions
outstanding from the committee so i will
extend my hearty thanks to
mr clapp and ms minnow for a wonderful
presentation that helped us understand
just how expensive
distributed energy resources are
and uh we appreciate you being here
today and
thank you for coming
and the rest of the committee i will say
that um
right now the tentative plan is to
come back on may 3rd monday may 3rd
to hear senate bill
113. and
given the fact that there's only one
bill to hear that day in public hearing
we very likely will schedule some work
sessions
on
senate bill 91 possibly senate bill 78
possibly even senate bill 113 so
that will be the tentative plan and uh
i'll keep you posted mr chairman come
together
representative
yes uh could i could i ask you to
consider uh scheduling a briefing for
this committee on
the new
proposed department of energy
our committee has not heard any kind of
a presentation by the people involved
of this new proposal
and i think it would benefit all of us
okay i'll see if i can arrange such a
presentation
thank you
okay well thanks everybody thanks for
being here today
a lot accomplished i appreciate it
appreciate your hard work and uh we will
see you on monday
may 3rd
thank you